all right everybody i've got
no time for intro songs i have no time
time for videos of me
you know uh harvesting my zooks or cukes
because
we have tonight the uh decision-making
elections that will tell us quite
frankly they will tell us can joe biden
do anything in the next two years
i i don't want to make this bigger than
it is
i don't think it would be possible to be
hyperbolic um i guess hyperbolic would
be the world is depending on this
it's probably a little too much but uh
there will be
many many americans who
may remain financially viable if the two
democratic challengers win tonight
um there is a potential third stimulus
riding on tonight
uh public option is enough is like don't
even dream about it if democrats don't
get these two seats and i have to tell
you
so far things are actually looking okay
we have two
special runoff elections in the state of
georgia
with 23 reporting rafael warnock
is leading incumbent lunatic republican
kelly leffler by
seven and with 23 reporting
john ossoff challenger is leading
corrosive
toxic incumbent republican david perdue
currently quarantining
for covet exposure by
six those are the numbers as of right
now as of one minute ago
and as always the devil is in the
details
when you look at where the early vote is
from
very powerful early vote from atlanta
fulton county dekalb county
gwinnett county very very important
counties for democrats
athens georgia clark county we're one of
our first radio affiliates wpp
wait a second is it in athens or rome
now i don't now i don't remember
where is dub can have anybody fact where
is wpp
is that in athens or i thought it was
athens but maybe it's rome georgia
nobody knows okay anyway these are
places you would
expect democrats to be doing well
um and uh they are doing well so we it
is
we are going to have to wait and see um
and we are looking at everything
everything very closely assaf
plus six once again right now and
uh whoa where did that go hold on purdue
assaf where's
and warnock uh plus um
almost seven 6.8 as of right now so
very very important and meanwhile as
this is going on
literally right now there is a so-called
stop the steel
super spreader event i don't know if
this is
uh some kind of error or an actual
flowchart of supposed fraud
i thought it was like a blue screen of
death for a second no this is actually a
slide of some kind
this is the stop the steel pre-rally
rally
ahead of tomorrow um the official vote
count so i will be with you tomorrow
starting at 1 pm east 10 am west
for the proceedings in the house of
representatives a joint session led by
vice president mike pence but we tonight
are looking at
georgia who will control the senate
if democrats get these two seats then it
will be 50 50
in the case of a tie vice president
kamala harris gets to
break the tie without either of these
this is
both must be won by democrats without
either of these
um there will be a republican-controlled
senate that is the reality and that will
essentially uh impede joe biden
from many of the big picture items the
big items that he wants to do so
this is all really really really
important so i have
tons of things to share with you today
but one last time
just an update on the numbers uh
as of four minutes ago as of one minute
ago
warnock's still plus seven and asif
still plus six and a very very important
evening
i am so glad uh that you are with me
today
okay where i don't even know where to
start quite frankly because there there
is just
so much to talk about and so much to
discuss
let's look at um just a couple of super
chats
jaden says my grandfather in indiana is
dying of covet and hospice
oh my god i'm so sorry instead of a
hospital because there are no beds and
the residents are all infected
his children still deny the virus exists
that is horrifying
jaden i'm so sorry to hear that uh and
there is uh
listen real life consequences
this is not politics as sport i know
it's sport to many
but this is real life that's the reality
and we're dealing with a death cult
here's matthew who says may have cut
covet from my dad a nurse
who hasn't taken the virus seriously
since he doesn't work in the icu
we need the seats now more than ever
jeremy asking do you think this is a
blue mirage well that's exactly the
point listen guys
we have seen states flip from where they
were at 94
reporting and as you can see we've
already seen the just while we were
talking warnock's lead shrunk from seven
to six
and oscar's lead shrunk from six to five
this is going to be a long night there
is no celebration here i see people like
val
uh in on twitch saying no celebration
until it's over
of course not but you're not seeing me
celebrate uh this is very very early
very very early um serge says
david happy new year looking forward to
the 20th okay let's get to a couple of
fun things just because i have them and
we're watching these results come in and
we have plenty of time to continue
watching these
i have a couple of fun things for you
guys and before i even jump into those
i do want to say thank you uh to the 13
people
who just grabbed subscriptions on twitch
i really appreciate you guys and twitch
is uh we were just talking actually with
producer pat
earlier twitch and our premium sub stack
newsletter
are two of our big priorities for 2021.
also want to say a big thank you to
david hines who just grabbed a
subscription at joinpackman.com
putting us at 14 and yes i opened the
phone lines yesterday
and i would love to open them again
today uh we have a very modest goal of a
hundred we got to like 4 40 yesterday
the phone lines were quadruply
blown wide open so uh that was that was
yesterday
okay i have a couple of things for you
guys one i have a
hot new track for you which is the
wait a second where is it oh no i lost
it oh hold on here it is um
many of you probably heard the trump
georgia phone call where he asks for 11
780 votes dj physic
one of our great friends put together a
new track for us
this is called 1199 the magic number
this is a songification of trump asking
for 11 000 votes
all i want to do is this i just want to
find
11 hundred and eighty
votes which is one more that we have
because we want to say you know what
they did and you're not reporting it
that's it
you know that's a number of 11 779
that's the number
of 11 779 that's the number
of eleven thousand seven hundred
nine eleven nine eleven eight nine
eleven
nine that's something i think everyone
at least that's the number that everyone
agrees on
but that's the difference uh in the
votes
but we've had uh hundreds of thousands
of ballots that we're
uh we're able to actually we'll
get you a pretty accurate number you
don't need much of a number because the
number that
in theory i lost by the number of eleven
thousand seven hundred and seven okay so
you guys get the idea that's a perfect
new track
and then one other one he this is a new
only fans track i don't know if you guys
remember this call but a caller named
flippy from indiana called in
and said it's time for me to show my
zooks um
on an only fans that has now oh wait a
second what is this
uh did i oh here it is this is now a
songification of that this is the
it's time phone call this is from
betazoid lippy from
indiana flippy from indiana please
unmute you are on the air my friend hi
can you hear me yes i can hey david it's
me
um i just was wondering if you've ever
reconsidered making an only benz
sorry if i if i've done making an
omelette what no no making it only fans
uh you know
earnings season is over and it's time
for you to show us your zucchini
[Music]
that's very clever no listen um i think
i'd be more likely uh i'd be more likely
to show my
my granny smith apples than any zooks
floppy dukes flippy floppy uh floppy
dukes
floppy dukes flippy floppy
five and a quarter
oh my god that is just perfect so really
really powerful uh day from the
standpoint of music here
um at the david pakman show and i uh
i i really appreciate everybody sending
in those songs the uh you guys remember
remember
those it was literally a floppy disk
like it was it was
soft i don't know how else to describe
it uh bendable i guess would be the word
and
i remember i was sort of at the end of
that when i
became when i entered the world of
computing um
the three and a half incher was was
pretty widespread
a firm as you know and the five and a
quarter floppy was sort of like a relic
it was like a goof you would goof on the
five and a quarter
okay very good david says black lives
matter should wear pink to the rallies
tomorrow
no way proud boys won't wear pink
fragile masculinity whoa
that's aggressive brendan asking if i've
received any voicemails from prick the
prickles guy
recently i have not and i don't want to
say one way or the other
but the fbi did recently visit some of
our callers
and that likely will impact the number
of calls we're receiving from some
people i don't want to say too much more
but what i will
tell you is that repeater has continued
to call in basically at any time that i
check
our voicemail line repeater has called
recently
his last call is 61 minutes ago this is
the latest from re peter
take a listen here
david there wasn't anything wrong with
the phone call
yesterday everything trump said in the
phone call
there are videos we're talking videos
to back up what he was saying and so
that's repeater
61 minutes ago here is repeater 68
minutes ago
well david i've seen you let your last
youtube
uh video you're having another one of
your psychotic
episodes about this phone call
and then here is 96 minutes ago from
repeater
yeah david uh they're all like i said
they're already having issues with some
of the dominion machines in one of the
counties in georgia
and then lastly i mean not lastly we
could just go on
uh here is a call from exactly 120
minutes ago
well david they're already having issues
with
some of the dominion machines in one of
the counties in georgia
right so there's four phone calls from
repeater
and then just to kind of close the loop
on repeater this is fake repeater we now
have a guy who
satirizes uh repeater take a listen to
this
i played this yesterday i'll play it
again it's very good
hi david i said it once
and i'll say it again so why don't you
take off them high heels
kick them off the corner of your studio
there
wipe off that lipstick and listen
99 of
people who get this virus survive
that means that at least one percent
die it could be anywhere from two
percent to three
i've even heard reports on my
backwoods news network that it can get
up to six percent
but 99
of people survive so why don't you get
off them
dominion phone calling systems there and
and actually listen to what i have to
say 99
of people survive only about six to
seven percent die
all right so that's fake repeater to be
clear that's a friend of the show
that is fake repeater okay if you're
just joining
us we've just crossed the 25 000
live viewer mark over on youtube and
there's nothing to sneeze at happening
on twitch and facebook
as well uh we are uh experiencing
some uh very interesting early numbers
early numbers from these georgia senate
races
but listen i tol i don't i don't blow
smoke anywhere i don't smoke anything
it's bad for your lungs but
i would certainly not blow smoke
anywhere and when we joined when i
joined you when you joined me 15 minutes
ago
raphael warnock was ahead by seven and
john ossoff by six
those leads whoa hold on a second
those leads have just exploded we just
got a large
tranche of votes and rafael's warnock
lead with now 39
reporting has expanded to plus 10 and
john ossoff's lead massive dump of
ballots we just had a massive dump
john ossoff's lead has expanded to plus
11.
these are some these are some compelling
numbers
and you we are very quickly getting into
the range
where we can start doing math like for
example
if at 50 the lead is x
the person losing needs y percent of the
vote
to retake the lead it's only 8 16 pm
here on the east coast
uh but we are start once you're at 39
reporting you're not that far
by 55 if you have a large lead you can
start doing this math and we are
starting to get close to that so i'm so
thrilled that everybody's with me
as these historic votes are counted let
me say just a few other quick thank yous
i do want to say thanks
to the 22
additional twitch subscribers which puts
us at 38
and then also i want to say thanks for
people who just signed up at
joinpackman.com
jeff lawson is a new member susan
lishman
eva i hope i got that right
uh michael browning patrick rudzent
and brian gardner very much appreciate
that that puts us at 44
and we do have every intention um with
peace and love of
opening the phone lines if we are uh gen
if you are generous enough to get us to
100. okay as we continue to see the vote
count come in
and it is coming in very powerfully do
you guys want to hear
this is not a joke okay
michael cohen trump's former lawyer has
issued a an opinion about
about our borderline illegal membership
specials
this i'm not i'm really not kidding it's
really michael cohen
and he really issued a statement about
about our membership discounts
he does refer to me as david parkman in
the video
is that interesting does anybody care
about that or should we skip that
no people don't want it okay no i won't
put it i won't do it then i i have video
of michael cohen but
oh okay people do want it okay all right
here's the deal
our friend chakuseki who's actually a
radiologist
um hired michael cohen on cameo
to cut the following video let's let's
take a look at it
and he is issuing oh he says he knows
about illegal things
all right take a look at this let me get
this up for you
it's pretty funny um but this is
definitely a warning in the era of biden
here's michael cohen addressing our
membership discount hey david parkman
it's michael cohen here
yep michael cohen former personal
attorney and fixer
to now thank god t-minus 15 days and
counting
to former president donald j trump i'm
also the podcaster of maya culpa and the
author of the number one new york times
bestseller
disloyal i hope you read it so david
your buddy
chuck who said you asked me to reach out
to you first and foremost
i need to talk to you about this
borderline illegal membership
coupon that you have going for this
streaming news program the david parkman
show
well here's the bottom line i know all
about illegalities
i also know the repercussions for doing
things
despite the fact that they were directed
and for the benefit of
uh donald j trump so this is a real
cautionary tale
about the membership discounts as you
can tell this is this is pretty serious
one right i don't know who your client
number one may be but if you are
actually doing something you know my
client number one is repeater that's sad
right
that's borderline illegal membership
right to this um
streaming news program you may want to
think about that twice
because i can tell you firsthand prison
really
sucks all right being away from your
family and your friends losing
your business your credit cards your
insurance your car you're losing it all
it's true i could actually lose my
credit cards over these membership
discounts oh
right for what so another guy could get
his pecker pulled by a porn star
i create an nda serious so if i can go
to prison for something as stupid as
that
you can certainly have a lot of headache
as a result of this um
membership coupon so think twice about
that you may want to speak to an expert
yeah i possibly could have helped you
but unfortunately another thing that you
lose when you're a lawyer
is your law license so you're gonna have
to reach out and spend some money on a
lawyer to see if what you're doing is
acceptable yeah well no we've
isn't that insane guys uh so that is a
very very
um important cautionary tale there
from former trump attorney michael cohen
the membership discounts could be
uh they could land me in jail and that's
why i've already left the country
actually and that's because i'm trying
to evade uh
now and by way by the way by on the
advice of council i sound like that
shkreli guy
on the advice of council we are no
longer promoting how big the discount is
see how above my head it says you can
use the code better
21. it's now just a massive discount
i've been told that i will have a
stronger case in court
defending myself on these discounts if i
don't
promote the percentage so that's sort of
the compromise i made
with uh with my attorneys and they they
feel pretty pretty damn good about that
okay
so we've gotten that out of the way and
then
uh oh just one other thing sarah's
cat loves the david pakman show check
out this cat
tell me what kind of i'm not a cat
expert hold on i'm waiting for this
picture to load
tell me does anybody know what the breed
is of this particular type of cat
let me just load this and then i'll put
it up on screen for you
um this was from last night's stream
uh what what kind of cat is that does
anybody know
it seems farcical in some way
uh i don't know what breed that is it's
very very interesting and i have a video
of that same cat
loving loving loving the stream this is
from uh this is from yesterday check it
out i read the first two
starting the third oh hold on a second
let me get we're just getting all the
fun stuff out of the way then we're
gonna get to the to the results as they
keep coming in
uh sarah's cat here it is this is the
cat watching the uh watching the show
yesterday
and then i also read the first book of
the mars trilogy by kim stanley robinson
really really good stuff
and then for non-fiction i recently
okay what kind of a cat is that
it's a persian or a himalayan
it's a groomed persian with a buzz cut
okay
cool well anyway sarah's cat we love it
we love all animals
on the show and uh really really
appreciate that uh coming in and
and the cat really seemed pretty locked
in with what i was talking about there
all right we now have an extraordinary
situation if you're just joining us we
have tonight two
senate runoffs both in the state of
georgia that will determine
who controls the senate for the next two
years
a two thousand dollar stimulus check
could be riding on these two elections
the public option could be riding on
these two elections
uh immigration reform could be riding on
these two elections
on and on and on with 42 percent
reporting
lunatic republican incumbent kelly
leffler
is down by 11 to rafael warnock
and corrosive toxic clown
david perdue is down 11 to john ossoff
we now have 42 percent
reporting the numbers are stunning
the new york times needles
indicate that both what that
war knocks race is tilting towards
warnock
and uh ossoff's race is
tilting towards assaf okay
these are really really important races
i can't possibly overstate the
importance of what we are seeing here
and uh the numbers these are early
numbers
all we know nothing other than
right now with the percentage of the
vote that's been counted
in the locations where the vote has been
counted
john ossoff is doing strong and raphael
warnock is doing
strong that's it okay that's all we know
at this point in time okay a few other
super chats
desmond says my fiance and i
now that's interesting fiance with one e
is refers to a a man
and a lot of people don't know that so i
don't know if desmond is is
deliberately doing that or if you met if
you met fiance with two e's which would
be a woman
my fiance and i are loving watching our
favorite beta male and massive dumps
rolling in love you david thank you i
appreciate that
john says today is my 57th birthday and
i am hoping for a big
blue birthday present beautiful john
happy birthday
brooks says what do you think trump will
end up doing on the 20th seeing as he
still refuses to concede it's anyone's
guess
i'm taking this a day at a time let's
figure out what happens today
let's watch what happens tomorrow and
then let's see what donald trump
uh decides to do but what we can be
certain of is i don't know if you saw my
tweet earlier
this is the game plan if democrats win
georgia tonight
it was rigged if republicans win it was
fair and either way november was rigged
against donald trump that essentially
covers every eventuality
um for today so that that's that's
basically the uh that's basically the
bottom line i don't i don't know how
else to say it
all right my friends um okay let's see
other super chats
the demon cats magga kids warn us
off warn us of yeah i don't know i'm
sorry i don't know what that means but i
appreciate the super chat
hey brother love your breakdown on
topics and they help my small brain
comprehend i'm trying to understand more
about
paygo i don't know why it's significant
yeah that's an issue we can talk about
again
uh helen says that that's a partially
shaved persian cat
hey david are we talking a massive
discount dump
yeah we're we're dumping memberships
tonight hey david long time listener
what can you tell us about the david
parkman
pecker pull i keep hearing about it more
and more yeah i don't know
what michael cohen was um
was talking about there oh chris says
can i post the michael cohen file
somewhere because that would be great
for a remix
that would be great okay i don't know
how to where to post it
if you want to remix the michael cohen
david pakman
phone call email email in
and then i'll get you i'll figure out a
way to get you the file i think that
that's uh that's a really good idea
by the way so let me i'll tell you guys
a little this is a really funny story
the um the guy the the person who
request who put together the michael
cohen um
video about the david pakman show
membership specials
we know him on streams as chakaseki
and chakaseki over time he's been a big
supporter he revealed he's actually a
physician
he's a he's a medical doctor a uh a
radiologist
and just with the with the guys we were
talking about who is this guy and we
just we just googled him by his real
name and i won't out who he is
and we found like his medical practice
page
and his his uh like portrait with the uh
with the lab coat and everything and so
i have drawn up this scenario in my mind
where i'm imagining i for some reason i
imagine radiologists are in the basement
of the hospital even though they could
really be anywhere and right now they're
probably at home because they're just
reviewing images
i imagine chakaseki radiologist in his
lab coat
in a dark basement on a computer with
two screens
on one he's writing up reports about
radio radiology images
and on the other he's typing out a
script for michael cohen
to say something about the the david
parkman pecker pull
or whatever else that that's like the
image i have
the scenario i've drawn up about uh
how these things all go down and it may
be nothing like that
it may be nothing like that i imagine
he's going from saying yes patient
clearly has a uh stress fracture on the
left ankle
uh and then oh my michael cohen please
send a message to david pakman i'm sure
he's way more professional than that
but i don't i don't know mike says dave
had been watching your videos on youtube
the last two months regards to the
election your videos are great keep it
up man thank you i appreciate that
have i heard about the massive new
year's eve party in newark norcal
lots of nurses present from area
hospitals i did hear about that and it's
wacky
it's completely wacky let's get a vote
count update
uh with 44 reporting the margin
has shrunk a little bit rafael warnock
is now leading
the incumbent uh republican kelly
leffler by 10
and john ossoff is leading the incumbent
republican
david perdue by nine now i want to
i don't want to get ahead of where the
data is but i also
don't want to sort of uh um
pretend like this isn't something that's
going on
um we are starting to get close to
when we get we're at 45 reporting
when we get to 50 55 58 59
if the margins stay this large
it's not inconceivable that these races
could
become mathematically out of reach for
the candidates losing at that point in
time i'm not
i'm not gonna jinx anything i'm just
saying if you have a margin of eight or
nine
by the time you get to 60-ish you start
to say well
the the person who's behind needs
65 of the remaining vote how likely is
that
if the lead persists up to 65 reporting
you could say well
they're gonna need to get 70 of the
remaining votes so
the the vote is actually coming in fast
enough
that um we we could be a half
hour if the leads don't shrink that's a
big if
big if if the leads don't shrink we
could be about a half hour
from getting some relevant data
about what needs to happen uh in the
remaining period of time
for these numbers to turn around it's
early
and we're not going to get ahead of
ourselves and as people are pointing out
yeah let's do that next
if you look at some of these maps this
is this is just um
this is what this is which one this is
warnock lefler
if you look at atlanta fulton county 82
percent of the vote is in
dekalb oh only 27 there okay well that's
good for warnock
gwinnett 20 actually yeah so fulton
county is in very strongly
but a lot of these other areas i
understand that some red areas have like
here you have all these counties with
just two percent but there's almost no
people there
so all we can do is wait all we can do
is wait and that's exactly
that is exactly what we are doing right
now
um okay let's see here
um a few other thank yous
i do want to say thanks to the 19
additional twitch subscribers
which puts us at 63
um and then over on the website
i also want to say hold on a second one
two three four
five six seven i want to say thanks to
an additional 27 people who signed up
which puts us actually at exactly 90
and uh we will we will get some
guaranteed open phone lines
if we get to 100. all right so very
important stuff that is going on
um sari says on twitch i can't believe
we're still seeing more lawsuits and bs
from trump
it's uh it's insane and by the way i
mentioned this at the top
right now oh i guess it's over oh it
ended
right oh no it's still is it still going
on no it's not okay
there was a stop the steel rally just
going on for hour oh and now they
deleted the video
okay the stop the steel rally is over
and there's going to be another rally
tomorrow um and and by the way oh i
should even mention that actually
donald trump has tweeted that he will be
speaking tomorrow i will be speaking at
the save
america rally tomorrow on the ellipse at
11am eastern
arrive early dorzo can you imagine
showing up at 7am
to see trump lie about the election
being stolen
arrive early doors open at 7am eastern
big crowds so i don't know
that i'll be able to cover that the the
house and senate proceedings start at 1
pm eastern
and so our plan was to film the the
tomorrow's show
earlier um so that i could cover that
live
and uh i i that's the plan i don't think
i can be done
early enough that i could cover that
trump nonsense
uh but we'll see we'll see sort of what
what the day brings yeah some people
suggesting i start streaming on twitch
at 7am
that's not going to happen i'm not even
going to be up at 7am eastern
tracy moore cougar says found you last
night
and already have mad love and respect
for you god bless
tracy sending a 50 super chat i
appreciate that tracy thanks very much
mark says what is the covet vaccine
policy in georgia here in florida all of
us get it including yours truly at age
65
georgia senators will do the right thing
i don't i don't know uh state to state i
really don't know every state is able to
distribute vaccines as they see fit some
are just sitting on vaccines and in fact
i have that data
we can look at that real quick the
latest numbers
are that the united states has
administered 5
million doses 5 million doses
which is let's see exactly what percent
that is
it's 1.1 point something um
let's see here whoa
full screen okay five uh
5.05 million divided by 300 whoop
331 million okay yeah so it's 1.5 now i
actually let me let me play something
interesting for you guys you may find
this interesting
many of you recommended that i interview
uh eric topple and
uh he's a doctor and i did interview him
today and the interview isn't publishing
for a little bit
but the it's absolutely fascinating let
me just play
he had something interesting to say
about vaccines
i'll just preview this we haven't
published this yet obviously if you're a
member you do have access to this
already
let me see if i can get to that part uh
let's see um we we
got to go fast now this is a race
against okay nope that wasn't it
let's see where it was right
and we're not even at quite at 5 million
yet so
there there is an issue of course that
their vaccines have largely been
delivered
that is there's close to 20 million out
there now but they're just not getting
in people's arms
shots now to get this herd immunity this
is the only way to get to
uh herd immunity not through natural
infections through vaccines
we need to get you know at least uh
approximately 70
of people but the good part in the
united states uh if there is a good
thing this is important
is that we let this virus go with
rampant
spread and so we have at least 60 to 70
million people who have
natural infection induced immune
response
so you believe that's important now so
that's about 3x the official cases you
believe the real
infection rate is about three times the
official 20 million or so
that's right it was just published today
actually just before we got together
in jama network open that it's at least
3.2 x
of the number so we have 20 million so
we're about 65 million based on all the
the studies so the point here is that
we could get there faster go back to
your really great question about what if
we had a neutralization antibody to
the virus to the spike protein
uh if we had that and we could say
rapidly you you have you're coming into
your vaccine you're
you're in the line the queue and we
tested you and a couple minutes later
said well you're good to go
you're you're good right now you don't
need the vaccine we need to defer you
until we get to 70 now
if we could tap into that 60 plus 65
million people we can get there a lot
faster
but if we don't do that we're looking at
you know
uh uh third quarter at best that means
we got to get to two to three million
vaccine uh people a day a day now
now we're at five million after three
weeks and that's only one of two doses
plus getting them all a second dose now
the j and j vaccine which is
the jansen's coming out uh you know
perhaps early february
even later this month if that clicks
that's a single dose so that will make
life easier plus it doesn't require
freezing
that will make logistics easier and
it'll also add to our vaccine supply
but overall we're not going to get to
population immunity
that we need the faster the better
especially with this new
uh strain this new b117 um
we got to go fast now this is so this is
a really great interview this is one of
the honestly this is one of the best
guests we've had and
absolutely fantastic it's a 20-minute
interview we go into detail about
vaccination herd immunity
antibody testing if you're in one of the
five percent that does not develop
immunity after getting for example the
pfizer vaccine
if we could test you and determine that
would it make sense for you to then go
and get the moderna vaccine that's
something where
anyway we talk about a lot of this stuff
really really great interview and it's
on today's show
our members already have access to it
and we'll be publishing it
uh publicly at some point very very soon
so important stuff
all right let's get the latest numbers
out of georgia
we now have 46 reporting and
both democratic challengers rafael
warnock
and john ossoff are leading by eight we
are approaching the 50
threshold and um we have both democratic
challengers
leading by eight and we are standing
back and standing by
for further results mark sending us
a a funny funny spanish super chat
a very strong fifty dollar super chat
mark says
michonne
there's some literal i think this may be
google translated the syntax is a little
a little interesting
and he says david please more spanish
content
there's about 30 million spanish
speakers who would be fans like you
couldn't even imagine
i think that's a relatively accurate
uh accurate translation
of that this is horrifying every every
day now
i'm hearing from viewers with stories
like this roy
my mom has passed from covet 19. my
brothers still think
covet isn't real i'm so sorry roy every
i mean it's it's it's almost
unspeakable tragedy
where i'm getting 10 messages like this
a day from people in the audience
that's the scope of what's going on i'm
sending you my best roy i
it's it's that's just absolutely
horrifying and
um you know we we want to believe
that this will just be fixed someday at
some point
and it's just not going to be that way
it's a tragedy it will continue being a
tragedy
it's uh it's it's completely
inconceivable
and part of the start is trump just has
to go
republicans can't be controlling the
senate and that's that's quite literally
what we're standing by
for right now and as you can see the
leads have shrunk by 50 percent
leads that 15 minutes ago were 11 and 12
have shrunk to seven as we are breaching
the 50 reported mark uh both warnock and
ossoff down to plus seven
now when we were you know when we're
talking about
uh half a point separating some races
uh on november third plus seven is still
a massive massive lead massive massive
lead
but um we just all we can do is wait
all right let's see what the washington
post coverage is doing just who will
come out to vote is so essential
and who will be motivated who will be
inspired to vote
we did hear from nicole ellis
some young voters who were voting for
the very first time so there has been a
continued effort to try to target
communities
including people who perhaps didn't vote
in the 2020 general election ronda
that's right and this is just coming
after the general election when
a lot of voting rights advocates that i
i spoke with during the
so many first-time voters the point
that's being made
there i believe cbs is going to be going
to
a sort of county-by-county analysis when
they get back
and i do want to hear a little bit of
that so we're going to keep an
eye out i do want to get updated in
terms of our numbers here i'm sorry that
i've neglected that
we do have an additional 17
twitch subscribers which puts us at 107
and also from the standpoint of website
subscribers
another six which puts us at
113 uh
very much appreciated and um we have so
much to talk about tonight
that i'm i'm not spending a lot of time
about on it but
i do want to mention that we do have a
new coupon code we're hoping for a
better 2021 than 2020.
the coupon code is better 21. it's
really cheap when you use that coupon
code we're talking about pennies a day
uh at joinpacman.com it's the most
direct way to support the work we do
it's the way that uh we we keep
everything but two percent you know all
these other platforms when you
contribute
they're taking slices slices slices
everybody wants a piece of it
but when you sign up on our website it's
it's certainly immoral to offer
discounts this big but we're doing it
because we don't want um we don't want
the cost
to be a barrier and i played this
earlier i'll play it again
uh donald trump's former attorney
michael cohen
did issue a warning about these
discounts that i'm offering just take a
quick listen to that this is michael
cohen
parkman it's michael cohen here yep
michael cohen
former personal attorney and fixer to
now thank god t-minus 15 days and
counting
to former president donald j trump i'm
also the podcaster of mayor culpa
and the author of the number one new
york times bestseller
disloyal i hope you read it so david
your buddy
chuck who said you asked me to reach out
to you first and foremost
i need to talk to you about this
borderline illegal membership
coupon whoa this streaming news program
the david parkman show
well here's the bottom line i know all
about illegalities
yeah i also know the repercussions for
doing things
despite the fact that they were directed
and for the benefit of uh
donald j trump client number one right i
don't know who your client number one
may be but if you are
actually doing something that's
borderline illegal membership
right to this um streaming news program
you may want to think about that twice
yep no we are i'm definitely going to
reconsider the the discounts because
it's uh
it's scary stuff i don't want to be the
target of a politically motivated
investigation or anything like that so
the point is
better 21 it works now if i'm ending up
in the slammer i can assure you that the
discounts are getting
shut the hell down that's for sure okay
some other super chats are coming in
claire houlihan says both my father and
grandmother got covered 19
thankfully both recovered my heart goes
out to those who have lost
loved ones very much so very much so
uh georgia make it happen i'm rooting
for you from
switzerland absolutely absolutely
um oh boy now people are texting me
because they're very
that's rude i should have turned my
phone down i apologize for that
um okay we're gonna turn that down there
we go
that's very very rude of me uh okay
realistically what would be the most
progressive policy that could be passed
if
big if democrats take the senate i don't
see some of the more conservative
democrats playing along
i'm not even speculating about that yet
not even speculating about that yet
let's hear from friend of the show
weijia jiang
from cbs she follows us tomorrow morning
elaine oh we missed it
thank you cbs news has learned about a
possible attack on the u.s capitol
planned for wednesday
the threat was captured over the radio
frequencies used by pilots
oh no
the chilling threat obtained exclusively
by cbs news
was heard by multiple air traffic
controllers oh my god
afternoon in new york we are flying a
plane into the capital wednesday
sources tell cbs news the pentagon and
other agencies were briefed today
about the digitized voice recording and
believe it was designed to suggest
hitting the capitol on the same day
congress is set to count the electoral
college results
the recording refers to qasim soleimani
the iranian general killed in a u.s
drone strike ordered by president trump
and came on the one-year anniversary of
his death
yeah i mean very scary very i don't you
know i think the
the veracity of that uh certainly has to
be has to be investigated
we have seen yet another shrinkage
in the leads for the democratic
challengers as the vote continues to be
counted as we've gone from the 30s to
the 40s to the 50s in terms of the vote
count
the leads for the democratic challengers
have shrunk
from twelve to eleven ten nine eight
seven and now the lead for raphael
warnock is six
and the lead for challenger john ossoff
is five
these could end up being very very
close races and um we still have
uh discrepancies in terms of the parts
of the state
where we have more of the vote and the
parts of the state where we don't
but we are experiencing lead shrinkage
as we speak and we're going to continue
monitoring these numbers
uh 54 of the vote now and
uh another little bit of a ping for
uh kelly leffler gaining by another 0.1
percentage point
on rafael warnock so we're going to be
watching that we're going to be watching
that
very very closely um and the vote count
it comes slowly then there's a massive
vote dump
and then slowly again and it's it's very
very much
irregular very very irregular i think is
the way that i would
i would sort of put it okay do you guys
want to see
um well i'll just show it to you this is
this is really pretty funny
this is lou dobbs on fox business he's
been one of the primary promulgators
of election related conspiracy theories
that are completely without evidence he
had a moment let me see if an ad
is going to play because if it is
an ad is playing okay whoa this is a
weird ad um
let's just skip that i have an ad
blocker i don't know why the ad is
playing
okay this is like this is just so funny
because lou dobbs almost gets to to the
truth
lou dobbs says how is it that we don't
have any evidence for all of this voter
fraud that happened this is so funny
take a listen
from the election and we still don't
have verifiable
tangible support for
the for the the crimes that
everyone knows we're committed that is
defrauding other citizens who voted
uh with fraudulent votes we know that's
the case
in nevada we know it's the case in
pennsylvania and a number of other
states but we
have had a double of a time uh finding
actual proof why so
he almost gets there right and i'm gonna
i'm gonna talk about a term here
momentarily called
doxastic closure all right lou dobbs
almost get so so many people if you're
open right you would say
listen uh there's all these claims of
fraud
there was there was fraud in michigan
and pennsylvania and georgia
and voting machines were stolen or for
peace parts were replaced
and there were massive dumps and they
didn't feed the workers correctly and
there were no sandwiches in the back of
the you know
you have these hundred things and we
have no evidence for any of it
maybe it's not true right so so that
would be how someone who is
skeptical but healthy would go about it
for the conspiracy theorist
absence of evidence is part of the
conspiracy
and the the term that peter begosion
i've i know the term from peter bogosian
maybe it exists
prior to peter is doxastic closure
which is where there is nothing outside
the conspiracy that you
allow to sort of enter your brain an
example of this
is uh sometimes in
you know extremely devout religious
folks they will say
i know this is true because it's in a
sacred text which was written by god
or dictated by god or whatever and then
you say
well what evidence do you have that it
is actually a sacred text written by god
well
the text says so right but
what evidence do you have from outside
the sacred text
that it's a sacred it's closed
it nothing from outside penetrates it
it's it's the
the term from peter pagosian is
doxastatic closure
it's not exactly circular reasoning but
it's
uh there's an aspect of that example so
for lou dobbs because he's completely
closed off
the we just haven't for some reason
we're not finding the proof
but all of the assertions must be true
whereas you and i say
well look maybe maybe just all the
allegations aren't true
that's where my mind goes and of course
they're not and once you introduce
the the concept of uh burden of proof
you very quickly understand so there
there it is
um okay oh people are saying that
there's been another update to the vote
count
let's take a look here um
five and four okay so it has shrunk a
little more yeah warnock now only plus
five
and ossif only plus four so the lead is
shrinking every five minutes the lead is
shrinking
and getting closer and closer so we're
gonna have to uh
all we can do is wait my friends that's
all all we can do
um the vote count continuing to come in
all right let me get to a few super
chats oh rob says did i see the dc rally
today it was levels of insanity not seen
before in the trump era
at one point roger stone got up and
stood absolutely still
to a roger stone did nothing wrong wrap
yep i'm prepared i always uh i don't
just like go live
with no plan i have clips ready for you
from the pre-rally rally i guess it is
today
um let's get to some of them here it is
just to say
thank you jesus so there's roger stone
here is alex jones we don't quietly take
the scam
and believe their bs we've seen the
evidence
the system has had to desperately
engage in this gambit to maintain
control
but this will be their waterloo
this will be their destruction
alex jones isn't looking so good
whatever happens to president trump in
15 days
yeah he is still the elected president
of this republic and we do not recognize
the communist chinese agent joe
biden or his controllers so that's a
very very sick man
um let's see other ones
name is alex jones ladies and gentlemen
alex jones
hugging each other obviously
i'll tell you who i'm excited to hear to
see it's you
the american people unified in
resistance
to the new world order
it's a mind virus it's a really it's
really a mind virus
we have only begun to resist
the globalists we have only begun
our fight against their charity they
have tried to steal this election in
front of everyone
and as i told them 20 years ago i tell
them again
this seems like kayfabe right anybody
doesn't it okay um
a locker up chant i'm gonna skip that
one here's peter navarro
actually i want to skip peter navarro
this is the one i wanted to get to
listen to this must not comply
if you don't want to take an
experimental biological agent
deceptively named a vaccine
you must not allow yourself to be
coerced
if you are living in a biological agent
fear of a non-lethal virus simply by the
same
cheap ordinary medicines used across the
world
when you know something to be false you
must reject it
period when you know something to be
true you must stand up for it
and you must be willing to fight for it
i urge you to mark this day
this moment as a united return of our
nation
to the eternal fight for freedom a
commitment imagine if this was like your
physical therapist or your kid's teacher
you know i mean i'm assuming a lot of
these people do work it can't be that
they're all unemployed
how would you feel if this was your
kid's teacher i do want to address this
right here
rob schmidt asked via a really really
strong super chat david will you get the
vaccine of course i will
of course i will and i know that there's
a lot of people planning not to get it
my hope is that um listen i hope
airlines start to require it for flying
i would love it we were talking on the
bonus show today even with a bunch of
people not getting it
um if i have the vaccine and if
an airline requires it to fly and just
to pick a place if
aruba says everybody coming into the
country must have a vaccine
and the hotel in aruba says everybody
must have a vaccine proof of vaccine to
stay here
i would feel okay putting the mask on
once there's a certain level of immunity
putting the mask on getting on a flight
where i know everybody's vaccinated
going into a country where i know
everybody coming in is vaccinated and
going to a hotel where everybody's
required to
show proof of vaccination um but yes i i
will i will get the
i will get the vaccine all right let's
get back to updated vote numbers and
this
is disaster
with 59 reporting
rafael warnock's lead has dropped from
plus 12 at one point to just plus two
john ossoff's lead has dropped from plus
11
at one point to just 1.2
the race is tightening the race is
tightening
and we're going to keep watching it all
right just a couple more
clips here here's the my pillow guy like
i say where the miracle that we're in of
all time
is had that not happened on election
night
they've been boiling us like a frog for
years and we've done nothing about it
sat back
they take a little bit of our freedoms
all the time and
and and this was what would have
happened if we would have had that
miracle
that they misjudged okay so he it's not
clear what he's talking about he sounds
like he should be medicated
um here is oh hold on
this is the one i wanted to check this
out this guy defiantly asking people to
rise up and not wear masks
so what i'm asking you to do right now
is to do
the great reset in a good way okay we're
going to reframe it
last night about 150 of us went into
whole foods
and we dressed up like people that
aren't idiots hiding from a virus that's
not deadly what a hero do not wear
a mask who here is up to the task of not
wearing a mask
i ask you again who here is up to the
task of not wearing a mask
really powerful statement there and then
here he is claiming that coronavirus not
coronavirus is fake
coronavirus tests are fake
my wife is approximately five feet tall
if i told you my wife is 125 feet tall
that's what it means to be off by 25
times
right second the ugly truth
the pcr tests are fake the covet 19
pcr tests are fake and if you go to my
podcast
you can hear interviews you can hear the
founder of the pcr test kerry mullins
explaining to you
the pcr tests are supposed to be
calibrated at 17. someone should write
this down
17 to 20 cycles those are calibrated at
40 cycles
what does that mean it means that it's
like your speedometer is telling you
you're driving
400 miles an hour when you're driving
seven miles an hour
whoa cuckoo for coco puffs and donald j
trump doesn't need their money donald j
oh is this
just from the voice it sounds like that
woman melissa carone
trump doesn't need their influence he
stands on what's righteous
and just it is people are saying stomach
turning in the chat
it is stomach turning the more righteous
your fight
the more just your fight the more terror
and people are going to come against you
and that's how you know you're doing the
right thing and you're on the right side
of history
you know what that reminds me of that
reminds me
of uh that reminds me of this right here
hold on
does that ring a bell to anybody this is
what it sounds like
[Music]
anyway that's what that last one sounded
like to me um oh and you guys want to
hear the anti-semitic one i mean it's
like there's always huge
there's typically anti-semitism at these
things if i if you want to hear the
anti-semitism i'll play it
i don't know if people want it just to
hear it
okay now our next speaker is one of the
most
fiery activists i've ever known
yeah she's tireless she's relentless
she will do research she's the only
person i know who does she watches
george soros speeches
but you know what happened when she
looked one of those up
she found that he was talking about
chief justice john roberts
like george soros owned him
retweeted it for she gets this
information because she never
stops so understand that that that's a
dog whistle
where if you understand the idea of rich
jewish jewish men controlling people
behind the scenes and controlling
entities behind the scenes that's the
dog whistle that's there all right
not great news out of georgia uh raphael
warnock's lead is now down to just a
point and a half
and john ossoff's lead is now only eight
tenths of a single point
this is the worst that the numbers have
looked
all night i'm just i'm just the
messenger
i was here with you when the numbers
looked good and i'm here with you right
now
okay all we can do is wait and let me
make sure that i get caught up here
i do want to thank the 11 additional
twitch
subscribers which puts us at 124.
uh let's go for 306 tonight because
that's the number of electoral votes joe
biden has received
um we got to like 4 40 yesterday and
then i also want to say thank you
to an additional 24
website members which puts the set 148
that is an insane
number and i really i really appreciate
it okay
let me get to some super chats here
um oh uh oh this is important
dally madison via twitch sub says cleta
mitchell trump's attorney on the georgia
call lost her job today
yeah so on that insane georgia call the
treasonous impeachable georgia call
there was this attorney cleta mitchell
who was sort of like on trump's side
and she was a partner at a law firm and
the law firm after finding out that she
was involved in it
she was fired today so she's done
dunzo mark schwartz says taking a dinner
break we will keep the faith going to
subscribe to the website bye for now
i think mark has sent like 200 worth of
super chats tonight mark i really
appreciate it
really appreciate it heather says i
bought spy
puts today expiring tomorrow market has
been very complacent and is not
expecting democrats to win
uh yeah as many of you know um my
approach is i am
long and i have just continued dollar
cost averaging in
when the big dip happened in march i
just kept buying
buying buying buying um in april i kept
buying may june july august september
so i'm not doing calls puts i've got no
margin i'm just
long dollar cost averaged
ultra wide uh total stock market index
total bond market index that's me and
i know people asking about my bitcoin i
did
and i don't know i guess there's no real
problem with me mentioning this i've
been
i've been in bitcoin for years and years
and years and it did hit
a new all-time high and what i did
on uh jan i did it on january 1st
actually because i wanted to do it in
2021
i sold 20 of my bitcoin on
um january 1 just to lock in some of the
gains because it's exploded
and what's crazy is since that day
it's gone up again by so much that i'm
back to having
the same amount in terms of usd
it's insane it's insane what's going on
and it could crash
tomorrow and be worth zero uh i would
never dream
of uh and of course i declare it on my
taxes of course i declare it on my taxes
um i get i think it's a 1098 or
something
but because i sold it in 2021
i don't have to declare it until 2022
that's legal i'm not doing anything
sketchy that's just the way it works
2021 you declare in 2022 beautiful all
right good
um other super chats coming in carrie
says this is scarier than a horror film
it is it is grace says i think
something's wrong i received my first
dose
of the modern vaccine in december and i
still can't speak chinese should i worry
yeah i would i would worry about that
current margins versus november margins
on new york times look
good that is a perspective i think that
we're going to know the results so soon
that it's not even that worthwhile to
make those kinds of comparisons
but rafael warnock's lead is now down
again
to 1.1 and john ossoff is now
barely in the lead with 0.1 percent of a
lead
look at that those are stunning
stunning numbers um and i understand
people are saying well
at this point on november 3rd purdue was
up
slightly so it's better than that this
is a totally different situation
uh and purdue now pulling even 50 50 50
50
alert 50 50 now john ossoff david perdue
are tied and now ossoff back up by nine
one hundredths of a point warnock
down to being up by only two thirds of a
point so this is very
close those plus 12 numbers 20 uh
35 minutes ago um
that's not the way this is looking mark
schwartz says one last donation before
dinner i got my 600
incentive and i'm glad to share it have
a good dinner mark i appreciate it
uh very very much appreciate the support
um speak to destiny
yeah i'd be up for checking in with
destiny if people want me to
um sometimes people get angry when i
check in with destiny sometimes people
like it i don't know
i'm willing to check in let's see if we
can raise destiny
just real quick we have to it'll be very
brief
very very brief
ajc.com politics let's see
slash politics slash
election results
do they have a good platform
um okay yeah i don't know that it's that
much
better than what we're looking at from
the new york times
let me see if stephen wants to check in
where is
stephen let's see
destiny want to
check in real quick about georgia
i'd be interested in hearing about his
canvassing and how that went
yeah i also heard about some some ugly
stuff that happened with his
sort of like lead organizer i don't know
it's pretty i don't even know if he's
streaming honestly
uh he says sure call away okay let's
just check in real quick with destiny
i do want to check in with him let me
see here
uh input device and output device
steven david twitch.tv deepak
pakman how are you doing today how are
you i've been looking forward to just
checking in with you
yeah well thank you for checking in you
know i've been doing great today played
a little bit of minecraft you know i got
back for my vacation i had some chipotle
today with barbacoa
so oh my god chipotle there's no local
burrito place you could go to
how do i go to a local burrito place
when i could support american businesses
do you hate the global poor dear god um
so listen
i do want to say you know you you and i
have had our disagreements over time
but your work canvassing in georgia
i don't know that i mean who else was
doing that level of organizing i do want
to congratulate you on it i think it's
fantastic
oh thanks i'm pretty sure we had the
largest single canvas launch
that weekend in the whole state of
georgia i think we had 140 unique
canvassers working over two days which i
thought that was really cool
it's fantastic i mean how are you
feeling about the numbers so far
um like wait my numbers for the event
are the voting numbers coming in
the voting number's coming in um i don't
know enough to have strong feelings
about it i'm watching the needle yeah
yeah i mean what else can we do at this
point right
yeah i mean it all if if i was
supercharging what you would want to do
is you want to break
every single county you'd want to see
the remaining votes coming in you'd want
to say they voted last election and then
you want to calculate like yeah but i'm
the needle does all that right i'm
assuming that the math guy is working
this are doing that i mean it looks like
there's a ton of votes still outstanding
in the atlanta area yep
um it looks like so far based on tweets
i'm clicking on it seems like
a lot of the counties are over
performing their last election cycle
yes um so i mean assuming that trend
keeps up i mean you'd expect both
warnock and ossoff to win this
race let me ask you this and if this is
like a touchy subject or if there's
litigation that we need to you can't
talk
about this that's fine i heard that
something really ugly happened
from the standpoint of your like lead
organizer for the canvassing event is
that true or was that a false rumor
um yeah that happened but um
yeah is that a sore spot well i
no i mean it happened it's just like we
got over it but that that's like a whole
other
uh conversation so there's a lot of
background to get into there but i mean
it's fine we still had
um none of the people on the ground knew
at the time of the canvassing and it
didn't like
hinder our uh efforts too much so yeah
okay good i'm glad to hear that yeah and
we don't have to go into it i mean it's
uh it seems like it there could be
uh litigation pending and i want to be
real careful about
you know uh not not getting into
anything like that um and then as far as
as far as
flights and just like coveted safety and
everything i know at one point i checked
in and you were
yelling at people to stay far apart from
each other like how did you generally
feel it was from the standpoint of
coveted safety
um i think the initial sign-ins were a
little bit rough sometimes
yeah um especially with everybody like
congregating in the lobby and stuff but
like once we got past that especially
past day one
um people seem to be sorting themselves
a lot better um everything in the actual
room itself
all of the chairs were pre-spaced by
employees at the hotel tomorrow it was
covered safe and everything so
um i think in general i feel pretty good
about it maybe a little bit sloppy in
the beginning but i think for the most
part people did a pretty decent job and
then like everybody was wearing masks
and everything too we didn't have to
discriminate anybody over that stuff so
i know that there was a real
question as to the best way to feed
everybody which is really a big thing i
mean these are these are
they become logistical nightmares i've
been involved in small events and it's
just
every aspect of it is a nightmare did
you end up just getting pizza for
everybody was there cashew cheese
available for vegans like how did you
manage that
yeah there's a pizza place in atlanta no
not in atlanta i think in georgia a
chain called mellow mushroom maybe some
other places too but yeah we just we
relied on them we got there was vegan
pizza vegetarian pizza and then
meat pizza and then like pepperoni pizza
did you get like a meat lovers or
something like that
yeah it was i think it was the final
order it was nine meat lovers nine
pepperoni
three vegan and four vegetarian pizzas
is what we ordered thin crust medium
deep
dish um well i like good pizza so i
don't usually do deep dish
right i agree with you there wasn't thin
crushed yeah it was just like normal
pizzas we didn't get too exotic with the
choices though you know i don't want
people fighting over the crust selection
or anything so
and last question on the pizza and then
we'll move on did the did the sauce go
right to the edge or
or did they leave a lot of uncovered
area i hate that uncovered area
um well for a lot of my canvas areas
especially because we're trying to like
represent the democratic party in the
best light possible we didn't have the
sauce going right to the edge because we
don't want to get sauce all over our
fingers like barbarians oh my god edge
is like very good to hold on to without
being smeared in sauce like you have a
four-year-old with the crayola marker
um you know smearing something all over
a piece of paper so yeah that the sauce
ended in an appropriate
area where it should so that the crust
can be both held onto and then enjoyed
separately later on
good all right no no so now knowing that
now
what was the tone so i guess two
questions the areas that you guys were
canvassing i know that you were
targeting democratic voters and making
sure that they go vote you weren't like
showing up at republicans on purpose
and trying to argue with them you were
trying to get out the democratic vote
were you basically it was were you yeah
it's a big data collection process you
walk up to a door
ask them if you don't can reverend
warnock and john ossoff rely on your
vote you find out if they've already
voted find out people in the house will
devote it if they haven't
then you make sure that they're aware of
the upcoming election and the multiple
ways they can vote and then if they
don't know exactly how to vote then you
make a plan with them to vote you need
to check to see if you're registered
um you know are you aware that there's
absentee voting do you know this early
day voting that begins on december
um i think it was 14 i remember but um
yeah so yeah basically just walking
through to make sure that people knew
that they could vote if they had voted
to record it and then to make other
family members in the house aware of
who's voting and then figure out who we
think their vote is going for
because the democratic party tabulates
that data and then uses it for their
predictions and they're
advertising everything now were you
doing this in like
purple areas red areas or blue areas
so we focused and so this is probably i
think the most expensive election in
all of all time the most expensive
senate election of all that maybe of any
best-selling presidential um and all a
lot of that money is being poured into
tv ads and everything and all the
campuses are working in georgia right
now
so we went to the second largest city in
georgia um i'm sorry all the campuses
working in atlanta
so we went to the second largest city
which is columbus and then we primarily
worked
that county yeah um the county is
muskogee county i think which is going
very very blue by the way
did you um did you run into
trumpists who were either mad at the
fact that you were trying to get out the
vote for democrats or
even like mad that you were just wearing
masks
no the areas that we were in i don't
know
if this place is like divided like
hardcore like segregated but i think the
areas that we were canvassing were
pretty democratic
i don't know i didn't run into i had one
weird thing come up where
some ex like radio lady debated me or
something i saw that video i saw that
video yeah
that was that was like a twilight zone
yeah thing but like other than that no i
think most of the experiences were
pretty positive there wasn't very much
crazy stuff nobody like fighting us over
wearing masks or any
silly stuff like that and if i recall
correctly you stayed in alabama is that
right
um kind yeah so the city we were in
columbus
is um it's it's like there's a city
right across the river called i think
phoenix and
it's kind of like the same city may be
comparable to say like
kansas city kansas and kansas city of
missouri it was technically in
alabama but it was like a 15-minute
drive to all of our canvassing places so
got it and was anything anything
interesting on that side of the border
um no i mean it was i mean we were all
in it's not like we were outside like
talking to people anything it was like
yeah like we were just in the hotel
there and then we would drive over to
columbus to go and do our canvassing
stuff
got it all right very good um okay good
well listen congratulations and really
to the
uh to the dgg community that
participated
i i think it's fantastic what you guys
did and let's just keep watching the
results and see what we
what what happens tonight yeah true i'm
super proud of them i'm really happy
they all came out and uh thank you for
the kind words my dude
all right my friend we'll check in once
we know more okay have fun because all
right so yeah there is uh oh yeah
i don't know if you're aware of this um
the dgg analyst desk uh made a big
prediction prior to you coming here
we've already predicted the election
for both warnock and ossoff both seats
are going to the dems just letting you
know that okay
okay very good uh dgg has made a
preemptive uh
it's not a premature call you don't
think no no we communicated with our
analysts earlier they're confident based
on the
uh outstanding votes right now and the
counties that they are outstanding in
and there's just no mathematical way
possible for the republicans to win
going forward so
okay all right very good well that is
the uh analysis desk there
stephen kenneth destiny bonnell ii
arguably the best-known cuban-american
streamer i would say
in the united states thank you very much
all right there it is
uh stephen very very important very very
important all right guys
let's get back to the data um
we now have a situation where incumbent
lunatic corrosive depraved delusional
trumpist
senator david perdue has taken
a lead by half a point over
john ossoff that's not what you like to
see
rafael warnock has just seen his lead
shrink to just a hair over a tenth of a
point
just a hair over a tenth of a point and
this
is it couldn't be any tighter
right now not literally it could be a
slight slight bit tighter but but it
essentially could not be any tighter
um and we are i mean listen we're
we're potentially 30 40 minutes
before uh we would have something more
definitive people asking me to check the
needle earlier people were mad at the
needle
the needle still is leaning warnock
and the other needle is tilting awesome
i don't know how much this tells us guys
i mean we just have to watch the numbers
these ended up flipping
flipping and flopping back and forth um
on the presidential
uh david perdue just slightly expanding
his lead here uh
by five hundredths of a point so we we
just we just yeah i
i don't i don't know how much we really
gain from paying particular attention to
the needle
there's another two hundredths of a
point for warnock and another hundredth
of a point
for purdue and we are we are seeing the
count come in
by the minute by the minute okay um
let me see i know i've fallen behind on
a bunch of stuff
um we have another
five twitch subs which puts us
at 153 and i'm just managing a lot here
and trying to keep up
on the website we have another two
people who signed up at joinpakman.com
using the coupon code better21 take
advantage of that coupon code we love it
we absolutely love the coupon code let
me do a few super chats
um
oh yeah people are telling me about the
video where trump is a trump has debated
destiny in georgia i saw that
i'm not going to play it now but i did i
did see that okay
uh rusty lewis is coming up with some
pretty aggressive super chats so i think
just to keep it a little family friendly
i'm going to skip it but it's a very
funny super chat i'm going to skip
over it mac wants me to check in on
jesse lee peterson i think he might need
a hug
david next time you're in st paul
minnesota go to moochies off of randolph
if you i've never had a better pizza get
the camilla pizza
next time i've never been to saint paul
minnesota i've been to uh as donald
trump calls it
minneapolis minnesota
david on the topic of food is a pop-tart
a ravioli
no is a calzone a sandwich
absolutely not a calzone is an italian
empanada
it is not a it's it's actually i find it
uh discriminatory
to say as a sandwich this election has
me so nervous but watching live with you
and hearing your commentary
has helped keep me at a two-drink
minimum
i think you mean maximum right that
deserves another
super chat what happens if they're both
under 50
again impossible mathematically because
there are only two candidates right
there's no way
could they be i guess if there's a could
can you have write-ins in a runoff i
don't think you can i don't correct me
if i'm wrong
there's no way that you could have a uh
a situation with my both under 50
we're not sure yeah i don't think i mean
i'm not seeing
anything like that in the results it
seems very clear
there's not any other i think in a
runoff it's one or the other that's it
one or the other okay um raphael
warnock's lead has just doubled
from point 14 to point 28 that's good
and david perdue's lead has slightly
shrunk
from plus point five seven to plus point
four
six these are very tight races very
tight races both races now
within half a point if you can believe
that
unbelievable unbelievable um
rusty's going to put himself in time out
for the aggressive super chat no problem
white voters are destroying this country
change my mind
that's a little that's that's i don't
think that's the way i would analyze the
election
that doesn't seem like a uh prudent way
to analyze what we have going on here
uh okay let's see what
else we have people i see people getting
worried yeah i understand listen
this is worrying these numbers are
worrying there's no doubt about it when
you look and you see that it's this
close
and you see that 12 point leads have
evaporated
obviously you would be you would be
right to be worried
let's take a listen to the washington
post reporting briefly
an increasing focus on warnock over
assaf some daylight between
the two you know warnock the the head of
martin luther king's church
you know the the sp you know of a
socially active social justice ministry
and um you know and also you know almost
20 years older than uh than ossoff so
there there is
a little bit of difference but what you
also see on the republican side is an
attempt to
lump them together you know both warnock
and ossoff are radical and liberal and
too extreme for for georgia with the
thought that
if if if republican or even moderate and
independent voters hate one of them if
you lump them both together well
they'll both go down uh at the same time
you know
on the other side you know david perdue
you know is a cousin to former governor
sonny perdue you know he has that
that family name that history all right
so it looks like they are sort of uh
trying to fill a bit of time let's see
what's happening over on cbs
stories that are done and the countless
lack of evidence that's been there to
support it
there there's a strong uh a threat of
that
and they don't want to see those
irregularities continued
they want to continue to have faith in
the system and i think
that that's what's so unusual
you don't normally leave uh at a
presidential election and
kind of have these question marks that
are so broad for
for millions of people so
that's again why i keep going back
elaine to just how unusual this
is and i don't think we're going to see
answers tonight that are going to really
give us insights to what to expect at
21.
all right absolutely perfect perfect
lighting there
um okay i saw a super chat i did want to
address
um when trump was talking earlier about
maya culpa county was he admitting it's
all his fault yeah i actually want to
look at that because that's a funny
thing
this happened yesterday um let me see if
i can
find it hold on i know aaron rupar had
the clip
uh okay so first of all trump botched
the word america yesterday just as a
quick reminder
we have made america strong again look
at that arm
okay but then this was funny trump
couldn't say
maricopa county and uh
he called it maya copa i love this
moment take it check this out
this is constituents reported that their
earlier in-person ballots may not have
been correctly processed or tabulated in
myacopa county officials i it's like
what i love about that is everything
he's saying is so stupid
he told hundreds of lies at this thing
yesterday
but the fact that he's also lying about
maya copa county
for some reason i find it it's like just
an extra level
an extra level of hilarity okay um
let's get uh okay okay people are
yelling at me both
republicans are now in the lead
69 reporting kelly leffler is now
ahead by a third of a point
while david perdue for the first time in
the evening has gotten to a
full point a full point in the lead
a full point in the lead with 69
reporting the needles still leaning
warnock
and the needles still tilting asaf
that's all we know at this point in time
and we are still waiting
for some of the vote from fulton county
where atlanta is that's been stuck at 86
for a while
um we have 88 in from augusta
we have only 48 in from muskogee county
muskogee county could end up being the
difference maker
because that is going basically four to
one for warnock
and let's see how it's going it's going
four to four to one for warnock and four
to one for assaf almost identical
and they have only 48 percent of the
vote counted so
doing some quick math actually let's do
it
this is not this is not you know
advanced math necessarily
um let's just figure it out if right now
the margin is uh 23689
minus 8352 with 48
reporting we could expect an eventual
margin of 31952
uh minus 15 337. okay so that would
basically be plus 16
6 and it's like okay so
if you this is just an example of why it
matters where the vote is coming from
if you just pretend that the only thing
left to count was 52
of the ballot in that one county we
would expect that the remaining
votes would flip the leftler warnock
lead
to warnock and would uh i believe it
would also flip this other one let me
see
not quite it would not flip the lead to
ossoff but that alone if if that if we
continue to see a 73 to 27 split in
muskogee county
that would be more than enough to close
the gap between lefleur and warnock
it's you know i mean we're just we're
all just trying to figure out the
direction this is going
uh david perdue's lead now going up by
another 20
from 1 to 1.2 and kelly lefler's lead
going up uh from 0.3
to 0.42 okay so that is continuing to
uh go in the direction of the two
republican candidates
for the time being for the time being
sam cedar called the race i don't even
know what that means
i wonder if we could get on with sam
um let's see
i don't even know if he's streaming hey
are you streaming want
to connect briefly
let's see that would be interesting we
haven't checked in with sam for a while
um that would be that would be i would
be interested in that
okay i do want to say thank you to the
eight
folks who just signed up at
joinpackman.com
putting us at 163 also
a very very big thank you to
thunder political puppy shell marley
and carsten wawer who have signed up via
twitch
uh getting us to 167 i really appreciate
that
um let me see here
sam i don't know
yeah i don't know it's just complex sam
wants to talk
i don't even know what's going on with
sam let's just see if we can find him
sam where is it here's majority report
let's see if he's even live
first thing
okay you you would just be on his zoom
call while you're still on our zoom call
but if he came on our zoom call but how
would i do
both the zoom calls simultaneously oh
they're talking about me on getting on i
think
at once can i be on two zoom calls
simultaneously i don't know that
but you do have two computers set up
there don't you i think
the easiest way would be for him to join
our call yeah i'm glad to do that window
of
us oh i see okay yeah i think he did
this before
i can call into any zoom oh i'm not even
logged in doing this on the fly
yeah here we go there we go all right
let's send uh let's see
okay i just heard from sam we'll send a
zoom link okay contact him beautiful how
do we contact him
oh here they are yes how are you
contacting him i don't know it's his
phone number but i'm getting a call from
uh the
hello that's not me
hi missy wow it's crazy
okay so i told him to just email me the
zoom link and then we'll we'll get that
going we'll check in with sam
cedar and let's see
if they uh send me that link
okay i'll stand by i'll stand by for
them to send me that link
and then we'll we'll get on with sam um
i think at some point
okay uh kelly lefler's lead growing
david perdue's lead
growing it's it's not good it's not good
right now but we're gonna watch all of
these numbers
very very closely um oh okay let me see
here
someone emailed me and they're really
mad i miss their super chat
let me see if i can find it uh kale
okay here it is let's see kale emailed
me because they're mad that they paid 10
bucks and i didn't respond did not see
how the fiance comment was relevant let
alone appropriate please check yourself
good sir
i i i the the comment was fine i don't i
can't tell you anything
else was that the only one yep okay
kale i uh thank you i've i've addressed
your super chat
i uh i don't know what to tell you buddy
okay very good um no email from sam's
production team
yet but uh
we'll send a zoom link sam says okay
all right good so we're standing by for
that
i think that we should probably be
receiving that soon okay
uh i i'm not gonna lie i mean these
numbers are creeping in a direction
that's not particularly good
uh david perdue now up a full point and
a half as we get to 70
reporting and um
lefleur at point 76
0.76 and 1.5 at this point
with 70 70 70 70
reporting uh majority report zoom okay
let's see if i can connect here
um we're going to talk to sam
and we'll see what the right way is to
put this all up on screen
quite frankly i don't know host is gonna
let me in soon okay this is good
i'm curious what sam makes of all of
this
maybe we'll even uh okay so we're
standing by for that oh hold on i think
they're letting me in now
let's see join with computer i have a
report from
georgia from our correspondent on the
ground thank you
uh very much uh and now let's welcome to
the program
david pakman uh david uh how are you sir
uh i am doing well sir thank you we just
had a
live report from our correspondent in uh
georgia do you have one of those
uh well yes i actually i had a whole
team there that was canvassing but i
actually
was listening to your stream and i know
that you have no one in georgia
there's not even the remote possibility
anyone is in georgia for you right now
and this is almost as bad as uh that
thing that's been happening on twitch
between you know who and that other
woman you know
well i'm sorry i didn't uh your sound's
not good i could not make
anything you just said david
[Music]
i like that we can see the background
yeah now what's going on now that's not
the image that your uh
audience is seeing because it really is
i'm seeing your entire studio there yeah
i have to send you webcam audio because
uh
i can't i can't zoom with my good camera
if that makes sense
yeah okay great um it i guess it does
uh makes sense um but it is revealing
uh just how dramatic the
theft of my backdrop uh is when
when you see it in that way it's
extremely looks even more stark
the real the only difference is i have
improved upon your setup and i'll tell
you exactly how
um i am using pvc and if the pvc were to
fall on my head
i'd be fine and i recall that you used
plumbing pipe two-inch plumbing pipe
which you could get concussed from that
yes i did get i did get hit by on the
head from the plumbing pipe when we set
it up
uh and that is that is true but
everything else is exactly
it's it's it's shocking what about uh
what about
david's uh spinning globe there right
it's very
very uh new age newsy that's true
i don't we don't have one of those we
don't we we decided to eschew that
um i will say this kudos to you
for not what's that oh god what what's
what's going on now what do we what like
we're falling into some type of uh
i just wanted to see what david's setup
looked like uh i see
you're creating an infinite loop here i
am going
um i will just say this i i i want
to at least acknowledge the fact that uh
you have not
um put up a sign that says uh the
majority report with sam
in your set that would be too much that
would be too much
that would be too obvious so what do you
think david i mean um
we've been sitting here and really
basically just comparing numbers
from uh from the
general election in november yeah and
and relative to where they're performing
and it feels like you know the the race
is extremely close right now
i don't know specifically which i mean
cherokee is probably the biggest
republican
uh county as far as i can tell and i
don't know what the numbers are there
but uh we don't we don't have decab we
don't have
um uh fulton we don't have
uh cobb county in yet and
those are gonna be the ones that if they
follow suit
with the other democrat we're gonna see
big
big big numbers there yep i agree i mean
if you just want to say
i i just feel like it's sort of fraught
at this point because i still just think
it's so close anything could happen but
it is true that if you just say where
were we at this point
on election night it seems like the
democratic candidates
it's not not it seems they're doing
better than they were at this point that
night
um but i don't at this point i don't
know it's hard to feel confident about
anything for me
i i just think you know things have
swung back based on the northern
georgia counties coming in a lot of
republican-leaning counties coming in
but as of 10 minutes ago less than 40
percent of
votes in dekalb uh gwinnett and cobb
which are the
counties that are most populated
surrounding atlanta were
counted so it looks close
closer than it is right now or it looks
more dire than it is because i know
lefleur just
took the lead momentarily but warnock
i mean we could it's very likely that
warnock's gonna win the race i'm just
gonna say that
i think it's certainly that's the more
likely one if he loses they both lose i
think it's pretty clear at this point
yeah definitely uh so emma you just made
the call after telling me don't make a
call
i did not make a call i did not say
anything definitively
no no no no no i have to say it's a call
first
and i have to say i've seen enough and
step all over dave wasserman's shoes
all right do you think tomorrow is
likely to be
crazier or less crazy if we don't know
who wins these races by 1pm when pence
gets his
his dog and pony show going
um we were just talking about how i th
how sam was saying
and he can elaborate on this
that the georgia races going to
democrats
helps trump not republicans but helps
trump and his
ridiculous uh insane clown show
more than if they were to to win it
if if the race is not called i don't
think it implicates
the you know tomorrow at all right
because it's the same
it's it's status quo yeah if the
democrats win
it plays into trump's um
narrative that the vote is rigged and
the same people rigged it again and how
did
how was it so close and then all of a
sudden it at 11 30 p.m
all of a sudden 50 000 votes show up
that's exactly what happened to me
he'll say um if the republicans win
then i think what you'll you'll you know
trump will be it will
make it it will put pressure on those
republican senators to to to
it'll make them look worse for
contesting the election
because wait a second so you're telling
us that these deep state forces
threw the race for you uh against trump
and georgia but they
they want it for the republicans that
doesn't make any sense right um
and so you know i think that's where
we're gonna be at but uh but
but trump is gonna weaponize it in any
way he can i you know who knows
uh i i'm it's gonna be fascinating to
watch mike pence up there because yeah
he's really gonna try and uh split the
difference i i
you know i wouldn't put it past him to
have like one of those situations where
he's like telling his driver like i want
you to
fender bender fender bender on the way
to the senate
because i'm we're going to have to get
out we're going to have to exchange
like insurance cards and then i won't be
able to i'll
i'll miss the i'll miss the vote and i
think that's what he desperately wants
to do
frankly but is there any scenario where
it's any more than just like a two-hour
delay like is there any scenario where
this extends into tomorrow night or even
into thursday i can't i don't i can't
really think of one
the the counting of the ballots i i
i get the sense that this is going to be
resolved
tonight oh sorry i was i'm sorry i was
unclear i mean
the the counting of the electoral
ballots tomorrow
is there any way that that is any more
than just two hours of debate in the
house and senate and then they accept
them and then we move on like does that
go
beyond 4 p.m tomorrow
i think it depends on the margin of
victory i mean
what time what time does the uh what
time does the
the count start at two one one yeah
and the thing about this is is that you
know we'll cover that live
yeah yeah uh when did you say sam 1pm
1pm and into the fun half oh fun
uh so that was unintentional um yeah i i
mean
it it'll be interesting to see what
happens tomorrow with that i think i
think frankly
you know what's happening i i think
what's happening tomorrow
is going to be far more relevant
in four years or in eight years
or even in 12 years um because
what we're seeing you know we were
talking today emma and i were talking
about
we have a call we have a call we have a
call
rafael warnock defeats senator kelly
leffler and georgia's special
senate runoff announced where where do
we hold on i want to make this call
wasserman rafael warnock i'm calling it
rafael warnock
is going to win uh beat uh kelly leflar
go ahead i'm sorry did somebody else
make a call to
let's pull up wasserman wasserman i've
seen enough rafael warnock defeats kelly
lefler
wow so that is one that's one of two
[Music]
nice work sam
there's the shofar there's the shofar
first call tonight uh i
i um i'm i'm feels good
i'm pretty close to making the call on
behalf of ossoff too i'm
just going to wait until just a moment
before wasserman does
so um i mean this is
uh i so you know emma and i were talking
about
what the implications would be in
kentucky let's say if you had a charles
booker as opposed to
naming mcgrath as the candidate and what
it would do is it would be it would
begin to build an infrastructure
that you might see pay off four years
down the line
maybe two years down the line in some
congressional districts
maybe eight years down the line the flip
side of that
is when you when you keep
pushing the limits of norms
when you keep sliding closer and closer
i mean let's be clear
you to believe what is going on now with
the republican party as being completely
benign you have to believe that they're
only doing it that there's only 12
senators who are voting
uh to disregard the election results
because they think it's impossible for
trump to win right
and that's the only reason why they're
doing it and that if trump could
actually win
that they wouldn't vote that way right
and i don't think that's the case
i think they're just beh i think they're
just going with
what is politically um expedient and
valuable to them
and if they thought it was if trump and
and trump's chances
are secondary to to that i think
um and so i'm thinking four years down
the line
they have set certain benchmarks they
have
set certain standards and they're
creating enough space
for future republican senators to cast
these same votes that they're vote
voting but it may be in a different type
of situation maybe next time they'll be
24
maybe the next time there'll be 34 or 54
uh senators who will vote this way
because remember now we have had now
what is it i think it's five out of six
elections presidential elections
where uh republicans have lost
the popular vote yep and so they're
going to
increasingly have to rely on the
electoral
uh college to win elections
and if they have the ability to
short-circuit
that process then they have the ability
to basically negate
any type of advantage democrats have
with the popular vote across
the country it becomes less and less
irrelevant
and so um i i
i think it's very easy for people to
underestimate the damage this is going
to do in terms of the future like you
know you don't
you don't slide it you don't you don't
become a failed state
in the span of two years or four years
right
you become a failed state in the span of
50 years or 60 years or 80 years
yep and this applies to so many other
things people ask me how do we undo the
fact that
60 of trump voters believed as of a
couple weeks ago that he was actually
getting sworn in on january 20th
like it took that process started with
the
reagan welfare queen stories 40 years
ago and it's unreasonable to expect that
a process of radicalization that took 40
years to create
might be undone in because we get the
right president or a better president
best case it's a decade of of starting
to undo that
and i think it's the exact same thing
here and there's people in my chat
saying
sam is being cynical like no you i don't
think you're being overly cynical
at all um i have every feel every belief
that at this point there's really
nothing
that they wouldn't do if they think they
could get away with it
i i think that's absolutely correct i
mean i think it's look i i think it's
very hard
for
for the sake of it normal people to sort
of like grok this
yeah right like i mean it's i think it's
just very hard for
for for for normal people like your
listeners like our listeners
to sort of like contemplate that people
could be this
uh have this level of disregard for
um you know for what we take for granted
in terms of our the essence of
of our functioning society but with that
said i mean
look across the country you have states
that are
that are actively like um discouraging
vaccinations right and active i mean
there are
actively discouraging um you know mask
wearing
actively discouraging trying to avoid
a pandemic and you know that's also
complete i can't wrap my head around it
frankly and
and so um i think you really need to
look at history
and look at how you have the the the
the the slide into authoritarianism in
in the
the failures of of major uh societies
and this is the way it happens it
happens slowly bit by bit
and it's really more of like a trend now
i'm not saying this is inevitable
but i think it's very possible that you
know
um because you can't predict that you're
going to have
a pandemic you can't predict that you're
going to have
an attack that drops the tallest
buildings in your country
uh and collapses of them within you know
four hours and completely changes the
way that society is structured
these are not not things that can be
predicted but um
if you have you know like an election
that is really dubious
and then you have one of those things
that happens um
you know i'm talking about the 2000
election uh
you start to head down a certain path
and a certain trajectory and i think
it's really problematic
and so um while i think in the
the near term the this race tonight
is gonna have um the most import
i think when we're four or eight years
out 12 years out
16 years out i think what happens
tomorrow
may end up having more import yeah and
the
the authoritarianism is a good example
for the people who think that there's
too much cynicism here if you had been
told
a day after trump was elected what he
would do
in the last month very few people would
have been like yeah that's that's sure
that there's a real risk that that could
happen that doesn't sound plausible at
all
but very slowly it all built up the
attacks on media
and the ignoring of norms and the
flouting of the checks and balances and
all this stuff
and then look at what happened in
december it's insane nobody would have
very few people even us who were uh
maybe more concerned than some were
about what a trump presidency would be
even we might have said i don't know
that even sounds like maybe too much but
it just crept in very slowly and then
he almost none of the stories that would
have been
two-month scandals under obama are still
even being discussed today from like
october oh
yeah of course and you know i think
there there's a tendency for people of
of of our ilk for lack of better word
to sort of see trump as an anomaly right
and to see what's happening is some type
of like um
you know blip or fluke and if you step
back
and you look at this from a distance
it it it's not a fluke right it is
you know i mean you know you know this
from um
from uh you know just the way that you
you track data on
on your channel um i mean put aside the
whole bot thing
of course the like uh but right but but
things happen with spikes
right you get a spike and then it drops
down to a normal but it's a new normal
right and it's at a little bit higher
rate than it was initially and then it
spikes again
and then it drops back down to a new
normal but that new normal is still
higher than than it was and that's
and and that's what we're seeing here
yeah you know we we
trump is a spike but it brings us back
down to a
a level of normal that is a um
that is further along in a lot of things
that are problematic
that uh you know in terms of that sort
of continuum of authoritarianism or
you know kleptocracy i had an interview
uh today
with um uh her woman uh
sarah chase who um spent 10 years in
afghanistan
essentially um studying the corruption
of the
of the afghan government i mean she was
there um i think with an ngo
um and uh at one point
four or five years ago started to write
a book about just
uh broadly corruption and um
and she reckons that we are in a period
like the gilded age
from 1870 to uh
roughly the 1930s early 30s in this
country
where um where you know
things just became sort of incredibly
kleptocratic
and it took
a uh two world wars
a pandemic and a depression
to create the social cohesion in this
country
that essentially rested control
from these uh economic elites to this
you know
uh a um an oligarchy a plutocracy
um and you know to get the social
cohesion that we ended up having in the
50s and the 60s now again
i'm the i don't want to you know uh
paint that
that era is something that it wasn't
because we were obviously excluding a
huge portion of our population
civil rights civil rights and in terms
of you know emancipation for women and
for
uh for african-americans um but
in terms of that dynamic you know we we
are in one of those periods and
you know you're talking about a period
of 60 years right
um and we may not have
those massive sort of um
[Music]
uh uh you know moments that create
social cohesion
in terms of like a world war you know
having your cities bombed
you know all of a sudden you have an
outside force that is you know
that is basically you know we're all in
this together type of situation
um you know we had that after 9 11. it
was very brave
and and it was uh it was fleeting and
then squandered yeah
did leveraged it uh quite a bit can i
can i give a georgia
bit of an update though sure are we uh
is that a good time for me to jump in
yes yeah yeah yeah do it yeah yeah
all right good so we saw wasserman
called it no one else has called it yet
but nate cohn says democrats remain
heavily of the new york times
democrats remain heavily favored despite
their deficit in the tabulated vote
their favor to win what's left by nine
to ten points the biggest source of the
remaining vote as we've said
is the in person early voting
[Music]
in decal which alone could break to the
democrats by
a 120 k vote margin
wow wow well listen we clearly still
have quite a night ahead of us two quick
things sam
and and uh then then well you know
you'll let me go i'll let you go i don't
know who has to let hugo but
um one is people in the chat want to
know are you on edibles right now
am i on edibles yeah no you're not okay
i've had a little bit to drink but not
too much why and no i don't know they
were just asking is there is
does your chat have some sense that i i
regularly engage in edibles
i have no idea that's why it's it's sort
of uh opaque to me
but um and then the other thing is any
comments on now having surpassed the one
million subscriber
threshold like does it feel different is
it i mean you know
like to be honest with you
the biggest uh the the
the biggest change in my life is that um
whenever
my daughter is on a group
like facetime that she's got like these
like party apps
on her phone house party house party
stuff like that
her uh friends they're all 15.
they literally congratulate me is that
right
yeah that's amazing it's funny you
mentioned that because benjamin
benjamin dixon our friend benjamin dixon
shortly before you hit the million
he said his son was impressed
that he knew someone with a million
subscribers
and so i you have your your kids i have
no kids so i'm
i'm basically living through the
enthusiasm of ben dixon's children if
you can imagine
um uh yeah i believe and let me ask you
this and i have a question from my chat
please uh my chat is asking are you
uh profiting uh by your super chat
questions answering them on on me and do
i get a cut of those
oh none of this was super cheap i
haven't taken any super chats while
we've been connected
i mean they've been they've been pouring
they've been pouring in like
from a fire hose i just haven't been
answering them while we've been talking
wow all right well uh we we we've been
uh
[Laughter]
what was that sam now oh here's the
question i have for you how do you put
your don't you put your uh chat things
in your window
yes i do i am doing that show based on
you you do your through obs is that
right i'm using
streamlabs obs but it's the same on obs
or stream labs you can do it the same
way basically i have the super chats
open on a monitor
what is this stream labs what is that
obs is open source so the company stream
labs has taken
the platform of obs and kind of like
made
their uh yeah but it's all the same
in either case i'm using what's called a
display capture
i'm just capturing a portion of the
monitor and then placing it on the
screen
and and do you use uh are you a mac
based
show or a pc we are comp i don't even
know how
apple computers work uh we are
completely pc based
that's the difference right because obs
uh it's easier to operate with pcs
i couldn't tell you i mean it would be
easier for me i don't even know how to
use an iphone
now is it weird uh that you didn't copy
the fact that we're on macs
it is and it's in fact i was thinking of
copying that
the fact that you don't put super chats
on screen but i decided i
i just should do it right right that
must have been tough was that i feel
like you're out on a limb
yeah i didn't know if i could really
depart from your platform that much but
it's working
and of course i should just tell
everybody that i was wearing that
sweater last week
that you're wearing now but that's all
right that's uh that's fine
not the same size i assume huh no no
that would be yours would be a little
tight in the arms and that's only
because sam is taller i'm not saying
he's heavy for people he's just taller
than me that's all it is
it would have been it would have a
little bit tougher to get the guns in
there
uh david pakman always a pleasure
likewise thanks for stopping by
um but let me ask you this question
because you always you like to come on
you i always like to ask the questions
i do you'd like to do that i know that
but i want to ask you a question
what are the implications if uh the
democrats take both these uh seats
well depending on whether joe manchin is
at all interested in the things
joe biden wants to do there's a chance
of doing something
uh by a mechanism other than executive
order otherwise
it's just in the next two years none
nothing that is unable to be done via
executive order
can be done unless biden is willing to
compromise so much that it becomes like
a pyrrhic victory i
i just i don't understand how biden gets
his big agenda items done with a
republican senate
unless he compromises so much that it
becomes a question as whether it's
really a win in the net
right yeah he's gonna have to do i think
there's gonna have to be executive
actions
and i think they're gonna have to just
get one big reconciliation package in
right and they're gonna have to really
um use kovid
and uh throw a tremendous amount of
resources at uh
at covid because i think if he is able
if he
if he uses the defense production act
and gets um you know 30 million 40 50
million doses out there
by you know uh february or march
and and and i mean uh double doses so i
mean like
people vaccinated yeah yeah yes um and
if he can do that by let's say march
1st and and then subsequently you know
have um a significant portion of the
country 50 percent of the
the the population vaccinated by the
beginning of the summer um
you know i think this is he's got to be
thinking about how does he get a bigger
senate majority
right in 2022 and there's a couple of
opportunities you have a couple of uh
of republicans who are retiring and you
have some that are in trouble
um and uh and so and then of course
you're gonna have donald trump out there
who is gonna be presumably
you know um pounding on republicans so
it's gonna be interesting
but one other thing on vaccines just
this is really interesting today i
interviewed
dr eric topel who's really really good
on this stuff and we we talked for a
while
he said that um the new study today
says that the real rate of infection in
the us is about 3.2 x official so like
20 million roughly is official
the belief now is like 62 to 64 million
people have had the virus
he says one of the things that really
would be great is
if you can get a a quick result
antibody test a lot of the people who
are showing up to get who are going to
show up to get vaccines will have
antibodies because they they've had the
virus
he believes they should be deferred and
that that
instantly accelerates vaccination 20
because if one out of five has already
had it
and you skip over them it's not don't
ever give them a vaccine
if they have the antibodies for now and
they seem to last at least nine months
in most people
you immediately accelerate vaccination
20 percent just by saying hey
go to the back of the line because
you're actually protected right now
i can't i mean i don't know who can take
that and actually make it a reality
but the 60 million number is actually
very interesting because it means
we could have like 17 18 percent of the
population
immune right now at least for a time uh
you know i'll tell you why i'm skeptical
of something like that because
anything that's going to require the
level of bureaucracy that you're
talking about to make those assessments
it is far
more i think like you know i am i i am
of the mind that it is
far more efficient to simply invoke the
defense production act
produce the hell out of these vaccines
yeah both the pfizer and the mardurna
and you i mean under the auspices of
kovid under the auspices of a
reconciliation bill you can sell this to
the american public you put 25
050 000 maybe 75 000 people across the
country train them
in this there's already programs we're
seeing this in new york there's already
programs that county officials
you know essentially need to flick on a
switch they've had millions of dollars
of training
in terms of how to do mass vaccinations
and you just do
everybody who shows up sure you jab them
in the arm and you may be jabbing
you know there may be 5 10 20 of the
people who theoretically
you know could last another couple of
months but i think you just do
one thing and you do that one thing and
you focus on that and then you don't
have to worry about
issues of like creating a bureaucracy so
that you're gonna have administer tests
and then you're gonna you know issue
them a new date to show up
right sure you know like we're gonna
have so many vaccinations that
we just want the line out the door and
boom boom boom boom simpler
bureaucratically no question about it
yeah yeah so we'll see uh but uh dave
pakman
um stay healthy all right likewise yep
we'll talk to you guys soon
all right see you guys bye all right
there we go
uh leave meeting very very great to hear
from sam
and uh the big news is that david
wasserman
has called one of these races david
wasserman says
um oh hold on where is this
where did he say it i've seen enough
rafael warnock defeats senator kelly
leffler now it's important
this has been flagged multiple sources
have not
called this race have not called this
race so we are still
uh monitoring that but
sorry about that guys i don't know what
happened there lefler plus 1.3
and purdue plus two we are at 80 percent
and it would not be shocking to see
the vote slow down a little bit as we
get closer and closer to
100 percent all right let me say thank
you to a few other people
um thanks to ian snyder
scourge or scourge as trump says
and christy mack freedom
jesus galactic
toad and pat tad
for signing up via twitch that puts us
at 173
and then i also want to make sure that
i'm keeping up with thank yous
on website memberships at joinpakman.com
10 more people have just signed up which
puts us
at 183 okay um
a couple of other super chats coming in
catricelle
says love seeing all you guys together
keep up the great work
karen cochran says uh heck yeah david
i'd have never made it through november
3rd if not for you your demeanor your
red mirage and blue rush explanation
thank you no thank you karen um
david jason says david is the man
max says another senate seat available
through governor of maine if susan
collins accepts a cabinet position might
be a nice way to right her
wrongs that's interesting max says you
guys are awesome and emma is gorgeous oh
a little bit of a crush on on emma there
robert with a very ugly super chat
saying scam
cedar instead of sam cedar and
waller is me with a very aggressive
super chat
sam just needs 210 000 subs that's all
you're a progressive you want an
accurate count right nice background
you've got there would be terrible if
something happened to it
it's the david majority pacman report
show
with sam cedar i like that i like that
uh and then max says can't wait to see
neil katyal
on your channel great job pacman oh is
he coming on
i know that he's on a list but i'm
actually
you see here is neil caty all scheduled
to be on
no i'm not seeing it right now i know
he's invited
i know he's invited but we don't
currently have anything scheduled
okay has anyone other than dave
wasserman
called the warnock leffler race
for warnock do you know um
drudge report democrats now projected to
win at least
one senate seat you know i i read a very
interesting article about the drudge
report not long ago
that suggests drudge is not even
involved with the show anymore
and that uh it's almost sort of like a
center-left
site now it's very very interesting
let's just see what other result pages
we have here
cnn uh hold on where are these races run
off
cnn has purdue up
what is that 1.2 now no i'm sorry 2.2
next update in five seconds let's see
how much of an update takes place
none okay um and then they have leftler
they have leffler still up so not called
there um
hold on a second here we go
um everybody seems to have very very
similar numbers right now so as far as i
can tell
only david wasserman has called one of
these
um and purdue is now plus two
let's see what's going on here on the
washington post but in person today more
democrats take advantage of the early
voting
uh mechanisms in georgia so is that what
you're focused on
yeah absolutely libby and dave's
absolutely right
uh but the the you know you look at the
dekalb county margin and it's 80 20
uh which is is a remarkable margin uh
and and the question is how many votes
are still outstanding
uh and is that everybody asking the same
question at this point
anthony salvanto all right anthony the
races tightened up over the last hour
what is the very latest as indeed hey
elaine
so first of all georgia is counting
ballots a little quicker than we thought
they might tonight
83 in that's well ahead of
where this was in november but let me
show you this
first you see in the tallied vote right
now in the warnock lofla race
we've got 50.7 for the republican and
49.3 for the democrat warnock
now if i take you behind the scenes of
the decision desk a little bit i'm going
to show you
what our model estimates show and that
means
we take not only the counted vote but we
also take
the trend lines we take the counties
that haven't fully reported please
and we extrapolate what they've got in
into what we expect to be all of their
votes again
it's a model estimate i'm going to turn
that on and you can see
that warnock could still go up again
very close but that's 50.9
to 49.1 now why is that i'm going to go
back to regular counted vote here
and i'm going to zoom in a little bit
for a second and i'm going to show you
let's say cobb county where i think
there's going to be and there's going to
be like 300
000 votes there and you see they haven't
counted all of that only 55 percent
in there i'm going to show you fulton a
little more here 95
and okay warnock hitting his marks there
democrats got to
have a large lead there and in fact he
does i'll show you gannett
another one of those metro area counties
that's so important for democrats 89
percent in
okay so there's still plenty of votes
out there 10 10
or so of the voter and he's got a large
lead there and
dekalb here's a big one because it's
only 30. i am being told that the
associated press
has called it for david and that's
another place where
okay hold on here we go sorry that was
that was really weird i'm told the
associated press has called for david
perdue let's take a look
this is the associated press and as far
as i'm seeing they have not called it
for
a david perdue let's see
ap twitter let's see
nope they haven't all right you tricked
me wow
congrats um please ban that person
moderators by the way uh bandhammer
immediately please that's just that's
that's just stupid
okay let's do a couple other super chats
9010 dems on predicted.org
haven't been paying enough attention is
this race by voting district a
referendum
um i'm not sure i understand that
there's this these are two statewide
races all of georgia can vote for both
all of georgia can vote for both why
would joe manchin be a problem for biden
that's a good question so
the the reason joe manchin could be a
problem is joe manchin is the most
conservative democratic senator
and there are lots of joe biden's ideas
that it's not clear joe manchin would
want
would support and so even with 50 50
even with 50 50
uh if you can't convince joe manchin
you're back to 5149 and then having 50
50
with kamala as the tiebreaker doesn't
get you anything anymore
um david are you seeing what's happening
in hong kong right now i'm not but i
will look into it we're dealing with
this election now
when you look at the map for each race
you can see the shift from november
and it heavily favors democrats is that
on this
map um that's what i'm not understanding
uh like if i if i click here does that
give me anything
oh shift from november sorry here it is
okay
so there's some places with large
redshifts but then a bunch of places
with small and medium blue
shifts that's interesting that's
interesting yeah
um and size of lead as we know in the
big urban areas
um the democratic candidates with more
of a lead okay
so we're continuing to watch the numbers
come in
oh it's our friend dave weigel let's see
what dave is talking about
it's going to break for for the
democrats but really the story you're
going to hear
for the next couple hours i think maybe
a little a little bit of floyd county
which is rome georgia that's going to go
very strongly republican
but there's just not a lot else for them
to win so watch you know floyd
cobb and dekalb that's the story for the
rest of the evening
and whatever the there's enough to call
anything floyd's going to go republican
they're going to have some more cushion
out of there but if there really are
a couple hundred thousand democratic
votes in cobb and and dekalb that's that
that would be the election for both
democrats
wow stay with me dave i want to bring in
national video reporter nicole ellis
into the conversation
nicole reporting live from atlanta so
you have been following reverend warnock
and john ossoff
in these final campaign days how do you
think that rare joint campaigning they
were doing has impacted their races
thanks libby yes i mean you can see it
in the numbers they are
clearly neck and neck and there are some
disparities there and i think that's
where we can really see
the difference then i'm kind of
interested actually in the idea of
like how when when you have two runoffs
right
at the same time in the same state does
the difference between the leftler
results and the purdue results
does it come from people who go out and
vote differently like are there people
voting for one democrat and one
republican are there people that go out
and only vote in one
and leave the other one blank uh as we
see kelly lefler's lead go up
from 1.6 to 1.7 even though dave
wasserman has called that race already
for raphael warnock
um i'm kind of interested in how you
went like
why aren't the results identical for
both of these
races and um i know that there were some
enlightened centrists who
said well i voted for biden but i'm
voting for the republicans here
so that the republican senate is a
backstop it's like
oh right to extreme left-winger joe
biden who's going to do crazy left-wing
stuff give me a break
um some people are saying that there are
warnock purdue
voters that's interesting
um yeah okay well
that will be something we'll have to
look at uh a little bit
a little bit later on okay let's take
some phone calls guys i promised that i
would let's actually do it right now the
way to do this
is oh boy what is going on here i'm
getting a lot of really weird messages
on discord okay here's the way to do it
you go to uh davidpakman.com
discord you join the waiting lobby
and then you change your nickname to
location
and then your name location and then
your name let's just hear from a few
people
every time i promise i will open the
phone lines i do it
uh let's hear from a few people here
how about we first hear from
uh someone named liberal cuck
in virginia does that ring a bell do you
know who i'm talking about
liberal cuck in virginia you're on the
air yeah hello can you hear me
yeah you're a liberal [ __ ] um it's
actually a liberal cluck it's not
liberal cuck
oh like a hen like a chicken yes okay
all right liberal cluck in virginia
you're on the air
um i actually i want to ask you about
something that's kind of like old news
uh which is interesting because it
happened a few days ago i want to ask
you about
um the democrats and uh bernie sanders
um
filibustering the um defense bill
um i'm of the opinion that like they
really should have let bernie sanders
continue to uh the filibuster to try and
get the um two thousand dollar uh
stimulus uh on the floor um
but the other people that i've talked to
that um are against that
said that it would make um democrats
look like they're anti-trump
troops and such and um
i i kind of i i agree that that's a
possibility but if you look at the
actual facts of the um situation
the troops would have still got paid if
that bill didn't go through well not
only that not only that i would actually
also say that i i don't find that
argument compelling
because republicans have been saying
democrats are against the troops for
decades
no matter what democrats do and trump
said it yesterday at the rally and he
says it every day that he's in public so
i actually think it's a foregone
conclusion they're going to do that
either way so i wouldn't
that's not that i wouldn't i wouldn't
consider that in figuring out what to do
that's true that's true um so are you of
the opinion that maybe they should have
uh pushed the fight a little bit longer
or do you think that um they made the
right decision and
going ahead and accepting the defense
spending bill i
i i think that ultimately there was not
anything they were actually going to be
able to do
so i i mean i'm i really i'm
i'm i couldn't be more neutral in the
sense that i
i like it when bernie filibusters i love
it when bernie gets out there and starts
raining hell down upon everybody i
i love it and i also recognize it wasn't
actually going to to go anywhere
so you know i i don't know i mean
there's so much else going on
i'm i'm i would have been fine with it
and i'm also not now going to be
crying about it for two weeks you know
that's kind of where i think
i think they could have played a real
good optic i mean if they
were good at playing optics games they
could have they could have played a real
good optics game with it
to sort of help the georgia runoffs
maybe but um
democrats generally aren't very good at
that anyway so maybe it was best for
them to do that
um yeah but yeah that's all i really
want to talk about right now but i did
um do you allow people to plug
themselves on here
you're going to plug yourself right now
yeah so
um the reason i call liberal liberal
cluck on here is because i run a live
stream called
liberal cluck and i will actually be in
the um trump rally tomorrow at dc
um live streaming that early oh you
meant plug like promote oh my god you
had me scared there for a second
i didn't know what do you mean by
plugged in i didn't know i wasn't sure i
didn't know
okay all right um well i i apologize if
you don't you normally allow that
no no plug away plug away so you're
going to be at the rally tomorrow
yes i'll be out there rally
livestreaming my goal is to try and talk
to the trump supporters and have
a um a level-headed conversation with
them but
we both know that that's probably not
going to well listen
let me let me i'll mention something to
you i can't promise anything because
tomorrow's going to be hectic
but if you get if you or somehow if i
can get a link to your live stream
i'm going to be going live at 1pm with
the electoral vote count
if you happen to be out there at the
trump rally thing
streaming at the time when i'm streaming
i would gladly switch over and see what
you have going on
oh that would be awesome yeah so somehow
get a link to me of your live stream
okay
i mean you have it you have email right
i do have email
okay um i will go on to i'm sure it's on
your reddit somewhere i'll find it on
your reddit or yeah go to
davidpakman.comcontact
all right awesome yeah i will do that
thank you so much cool all right
pleasure there it is
liberal cluck from virginia beautiful
uh okay if you want to get on with me
davidpakman.com
discord and get in the waiting lobby
that is the way to do it
uh okay let's talk to some other
people um why don't we go
to let's go to amugo from
florida a mugo from florida you're on
the air
hello yeah you're on the air
oh hi i did not expect to be on here
and yet here we are can you hear me i
can hear you can you hear me i can hear
you yeah um
[Music]
yeah i'm just taking a look at the uh
the ross right now you know
a little worried but you know i'm a
little optimistic you know a lot of the
counties are still heavily democratic so
you never know
yeah is there a is there a wasp near
your microphone
uh no just this meme oh okay
i have my headphones plugged in so i
don't know if that might be it uh
it's probably the tv hold up let me put
the line down
oh is that better i think it is yeah
yeah so what uh
what what's your take what do you think
is gonna be happening here
um i think we're gonna see a swing i
just think it's gonna have to be patient
about it because
this kind of i feel like it's gonna be
the same thing in the election where
like you know
the day of you know everyone was worried
like oh my goodness you know trump's up
trump stuff
is he gonna do it again right then as
the votes came in it's gonna start
swinging the other way um so i'm
i'm a little worried but i still have
i'm optimistic
i'm still optimistic about it yeah i'm
with you i'm with you 100 percent
uh i guess the question for you is um do
you think joe biden would do the 15
minimum wage i heard he mentioned that
before
um during the uh the campaign trail so
if the democrats take the senate
wouldn't 15
be on the table when you sign it it
would be uh but
that you would need every democratic
senator to be in favor of it i genuinely
don't know if joe manchin wants a 15
minimum wage does it pass through the
house right so and joe biden said he
supports especially that last debate so
yep
yeah i mean i think it's a question like
does does joe manchin want that i'm not
sure
yeah that is true yeah yeah all right my
friend listen i'm gonna let you go
because i've got a lot of people waiting
amugo from florida
it's a real pleasure to hear from you
and a very very interesting connection
um sort of uh maybe you had a
maybe he's uh raising bees
in the background i don't know uh okay
let's go next to
um why don't we go to allen
from tucson arizona
hello hello hey man
oh my god this is not to like fanboy but
it's like an
honor to be on here with you oh the
honor is mine
um so about tonight i believe
both of the democrats are on their way
to win uh like the two biggest metro
cities
hello yeah i'm right here i'm right with
you yeah
okay all right um the two biggest metro
areas in
outside of atlanta still haven't been
called and those are going to be
massively democratic leaning
right that's just my take on it and then
i do have a question for you if you want
to
if you wanted to respond to that sure
um what do you think though if they win
what do you think the first thing they
do in the
in the new congress then knew everything
in you're saying not
biden by executive order but like what's
the big the legislative thing that they
do
either way because uh i'm assuming if
if biden does it by executive order it's
because he couldn't do it in the house
or anything
yeah i i'm not sure i mean joe biden has
put out his day one priorities
i don't know what the first thing that
the senate house and senate would take
up if there is democratic control
i think let's not put the cart before
the horse let's see who wins these
elections first
gotcha yeah that's my thought just to be
safe
and then i had one more question about
joe manchin being like a roadblock
right um do you think that
a barrage of like negative media against
him if he tries to like stop
like the two thousand dollar check or
like the 50 minimum wage that you were
talking about
do you think that would work against
them i mean
maybe the problem is joe manchin is in
west virginia and if you're a democrat
in west virginia you need democrats in
west virginia to vote for you
and probably some republicans so
i don't know that joe manchin really
cares whether you know
new york democrats are mad at him
because they don't vote for him
but you don't even think like a a huge
media like campaign
against them could work maybe yeah i
mean i think it depends on what
what the issue is that's on the table
like
i'm just like 15 minimum wage is like a
hugely popular across like
how you go against that and yeah like
here's how
let me experience here's how joe manchin
ends up i i don't know if joe manchin
wants a 15
minimum wage but let me i'll play out
how joe manchin
would end up against it joe manchin's in
west virginia
west virginia has low salaries and
terrible education and health care but
it's also really cheap to live in
so joe manchin gets a bunch of money
from the companies that are in west
virginia
and they are not going to want to pay a
15 minimum wage
so joe manchin is going to be thinking
okay my big donors
don't want a 15 minimum wage i'll just
come out and say
a 15 minimum wage as a blanket is out of
line
with the cost of living in in my state
of west virginia
and so i can't support it because i have
to support what's good for my state
that's that's how joe manchin
justifies being against a 15 minimum
wage
gotcha he's a real dick damn right
exactly well i appreciate it david i'll
let you
make somebody else's day all right
thanks alan appreciate it great to hear
from alan
snow white sending a beautiful super
chat says david you're simply the nicest
person your banter is delightful
thanks for helping me keep my sanity i
get a lot of emails that i'm too
mean to the callers and i get emails
saying
i'm too nice to the callers and what
i've learned from doing this
for a long time now is you can never
please
everybody even during the stream i've
gotten emails from people who
loved tonight's stream and from people
furious with how i've handled tonight's
stream
so you gotta just block it out i think
is the way uh the way to do it
let's go to a colombian caller in
arizona
arizona sorry colombian caller in
arizona you're on the air
hi david how are you doing good how are
you what part of columbia are you from
i'm sorry oh bogota beautiful hey i just
finished watching there's a fantastic
netflix series called
perdida which takes place in colombia
and it's really pretty well done i would
recommend it to people
okay we'll look into it please uh
yeah i have a question feeling all this
disarray that's going on
and the lack of ethics especially in the
republican party do you think there is a
potential that
after this is all said and done that a
republican senator might switch parties
um no i don't think so and the reason i
don't think so
is once trump is gone the republicans
are just going to
kind of pretend that it never happened
and go back to being
normal republicans where they pretend to
care about the debt
and that type of stuff so switching
to the democratic party would hurt that
story that they're going to build up
which is like oh we're constitutional
small government
low-debt conservatives so i think that
they'll j they'll just
keep doing what they were doing before
trump and kind of pretend trump never
happened so i don't think we're going to
see anybody
okay thank you my pleasure all right
there we go a colombian caller
from arizona um let's see where we want
to go next let's go
to april from british columbia
canada yay oh my gosh
hi um i've been watching you since
probably like a year and a half ago
when my roommate showed me you and like
i've been a big fan
um i love it thank you my my question
is is do people realize
trump has like
symptoms from cluster b personality
disorders
not just one but all four okay
uh let me look that up hold on cluster b
personality disorder
let me know personality disorder yeah
yeah hold on let me let me look it up
let me look it up i just want to put it
up on the screen so
antisocial personality disorder
borderline personality disorder
histrionic narcissistic yes i mean
listen
i realize it when you say people i don't
know it depends what people you're
talking about but
i realize it i'm saying by general
public like i live with borderline
personality disorder and there are some
great people out there like pete
davidson
okay the guy from saturday night live
right
but yeah he is um um but
like on top of it like you can barely
see the borderline because it's
over topped by the uh anti-social
and the histrionic which is him doing
the whole big
hands and like i did a great thing that
is a very a histrionic
personality symptom i don't i don't
think you're wrong
i think you're absolutely i don't think
you're wrong about anything i think you
know the value of diagnosing people from
afar
is sort of uh there's some value to it
but yeah i
i don't know um i do there are endless
mental health professionals that say
he's
he's unfit for office and i think
everything you're saying is correct
he does fit the borderline personality
disorder and
like the personality disorders yep uh
basis
he fits all of them based off of his
history and i have like looked at
it all and i have a similar not the same
like mine's from the poor side his is
from the rich side
um but he does have a lot of the
backgrounds
that tend to give people personality i'm
curious are you a mental health
professional
no i do want to be an art therapist
to work with kids in foster care because
i've been in foster care
um what field what's your feel what
field do you work a lot of mental health
disorders and i work with my doctor a
lot so
okay i'm just well well versed on all of
it
what what what field do you work in
um currently i work in no field i'm not
disability
which makes it hard for work right now
in canada
okay okay um and then also for me
uh my career is a bit longer because of
my background
because you have to uh fix yourself
before you can help others
right okay very good april in british
columbia i appreciate the call
very very much yes um let's go next
to uh let's go to alfredo from palm
springs california
alfredo um hello david
how are you thank you thank you for
taking my call i'm good
um what's it called uh i have a question
um i was a little
um it was it was worrying me when you
guys when you and sam were talking
earlier about
like the sort of um
sorry i'm nervous uh no problem sort of
um
like all the all the norms that he's
messed up and the
just our crisis of legitimacy where we
have a
like i go on some comment sections and
people
think that there's like like a civil war
is gonna happen and stuff
so like um what kind of like what do you
think is gonna
do you think that sort of thing is
possible like with
with all that's happening right now i
actually have a clip i'm researching it
right now because i want to get it right
it will be on my friday show and it is
exactly that question
is a civil war even a real possibility
so because i'm in the middle of
preparing a clip on that i don't want to
preempt it but i'll have an answer
detailed answer on the friday show for
you
okay thank you dude pleasure all right
alfredo there is there is alfredo
let's talk to a couple of other people
here if we can
let's go to jamie from beautiful
burlington
is it burlington vermont or
massachusetts vermont
vermont yes i love burlington vermont
beautiful it's cold jamie have you ever
been
to the um pha restaurant
downstairs on that pedestrian street in
downtown burlington you walk
downstairs into the restaurant below
street level never but i'm gonna look it
up
i hope it's still there it's fantastic
vermont does have some good foe
surprisingly
yes absolutely all right so my question
so it's popular like in the left wing
these days
to for candidates to refuse pac money
right but do you what impact on u.s
politics do you think it would have
if it became popular for
conservatives to kind of expect
that out of candidates well
if both parties if both parties make it
a matter of procedure that they don't
accept pac money
you dis pacs don't go away because they
can still spend on the behalf of a
candidate
but you at least start severing the
connection between the pacs and the
candidates to some degree so
i think the effect it would be a great
effect but for people who think
if all candidates say i won't take pak
money packs go away
they just funnel the money in other ways
or spend it directly
so i think there would be an effect but
i don't think it would be as big as some
people believe
okay that's a good answer um not to
throw a wrench in your answer but
from what i've read matt gates is the
only republican i can find that refuses
pac money
i don't know that may be true yeah i'm
not sure i mean he's disgusting for
other reasons but that may be true
all right i appreciate it have a good
night my pleasure you too
perfect phone calls today i have to tell
you really all just good
good phone calls um let's see who else
we can talk to
here what looks interesting
uh how about
there's a lot of people who i have
spoken to before i'd like to go to
someone new
if possible uh oh you know what because
we're dealing with georgia
let's go to sam from georgia sam from
georgia you're on the air
sam from georgia hello
sam we can hear you if you talk
okay oh you're cutting in and out
all right sam i'm gonna have to let you
go okay good um that's
uh unfortunate but i i would love have
loved to have heard from uh
from sam in georgia let's try
oh i don't know it's just so hard to
pick because there's so many people
let's try um
let's try steve from chino california
steve from china steve from chino
california
hi hi how are you hi hi how are you
can you hear me yes i can
good good hey i have a question about uh
you know trump uh everybody knows the
trump's
yeah trump's call in georgia was really
illegal it was
it was a
it was really voter a voter
uh rights violation
yeah but so was the uh
the lawsuit that was filed by the
texas attorney general sure and all of
the
other attorney generals who signed on to
it and the
republican congressmen who signed on to
it right
so couldn't they be charged with
voting voting rights violations
yes they could but they're not going to
be
steve okay yeah well thanks
thanks for taking my call all right
thank you very much all right guys i was
told to take calls until one goes
bad so that is going to be the last call
um for for today uh
we have a a really really long day
tomorrow we're doing the show in the
morning i might stream
trump's 11 a.m steal the election rally
i will stream
the 1pm electoral vote count so
that is going to do it for me as of
right now lefler plus two purdue plus
three with 13 percent of the vote
still to go if you're watching me on
twitch
we are going to raid uh let's raid
whoever i follow that has the fewest
viewers right now
we are going to raid uh international
master
eric rosen who is doing some chess stuff
right now
so join the raid if you are watching on
twitch
please remember to subscribe free on
youtube it costs nothing and then
tomorrow you'll be notified when we go
live with the electoral vote count
please make sure you're following me if
you're watching on twitch
we are at almost 70 000 followers which
would just be an
absolutely fantastic number i'll see
everybody tomorrow and twitch
let's go directly over with no delay
whatsoever
to the eric rosen stream
you